Barton Paulson is a university professor and
excellent instructor. In this course, he will turn
you into an expert in Google Sheets, spreadsheets
are a lot more useful than many people think.
And don't forget to like and subscribe to
the Free Code camp.org YouTube channel.
Welcome to Google Sheets, what I want to tell you
is that data loves spreadsheets. And that really,
you could learn to love them too. Now, you may
not think of yourself as a data kind of person.
But the important thing to know
about data is no matter what you do,
data gives you a map, it helps you find your
way. And you may wonder, a map to what Well,
that depends on what your goals are. They might
be professional, organizational, social, personal,
political. But whatever it is you're interested
in data can help you do it better. For instance,
if you have a business, it can help you figure
out what work that you do is most popular with
paying clients. It can help you figure out what
brings people back to your nonprofit organization,
who can help you say what attracts new
people to your political organization,
it may help you figure out what's the best
use of time in your own personal life.
And it can even help you figure out important
questions like how much should you charge for
your work or your services? So data is a method
of approaching any one of these questions. But
what does that have to do with Google Sheets?
Well, Google Sheets lets you do several different
things that are really important with data.
First and foremost in Google Sheets gives
your data a home. Now you know where your stuff
is. And you can find it, you can search for it,
you can share it with other people, you get it
centralized. And now you can do something useful
with it. And then what what are those things that
you're going to do? Well, there's a few things
that you can do with Google sheets that are really
helpful. Number one is you can graph your data,
you can explore your data, think of yourself as an
explorer, you're out there in really a new area,
and you're trying to find out what's all around
you. And what's the best way forward. And Google
Sheets, you can do that with graphs
like this multiple variable timeline,
it can help you find the places of greatest value,
and help lead you in that particular direction.
Google Sheets can also help you sort and filter
through your data. Now, you got a collection
of tea bags, put them in little boxes, it makes
it easier to see what you have, and also to see
what you're missing. In the data world. You can
sort your data by whatever categories you want,
you can filter it here, I'm filtering by a couple
of different categories. If you've got a business,
you can find new clients that are in your database
and focus on them. Or you can find open accounts,
and you can focus on them and take care of it. And
once you find the data that's most important to
you, you can calculate things about that data.
And you can summarize it really, it's a way of
bringing things in to focus. The entire point of
data analysis is to simplify things in a way that
helps you reach practical goals, you want to bring
it into focus. Sometimes the focus analogy really
can be pretty literal. Here I have a set of almost
1400 numbers, and it's completely overwhelming.
But over here on the right, you can see that the
mean, the average is 547.5. The maximum is 999.
I've got conditional formatting that highlights
where those 999 are, and also where the minimum
values of 100 are. It helps you sort through the
haystack and find the needles are going to be of
most use to you. Finally, believe it or not
spreadsheets and Google Sheets can help you
work creatively. Now, not necessarily to create
your own art. But if you're an artist, you will
find out that Google Sheets can help you free up
some time and some cognitive bandwidth to focus on
the things that are most important to you. And you
can be creative in spreadsheets. Here's one that I
use when planning a big trip around the world with
my family, I actually had to get a spreadsheet to
help figure out who was going to sit where on all
of the plane rides. Or you can use a spreadsheet
to help you make a decision about what you want
to focus on in your business to help you reach
both your personal and professional goals. I'll
give you examples of all of these things. And
as you go through the course you can follow
along by downloading the files that we have
at this address, data lab.cc slash tools
slash je s h that stands for Google Sheets.
01. So that's data lab.cc slash tools slash je s
h 01. Download the sheets, follow along and really
try Google Sheets and what you'll
find is that it's going to help you
listen to your data and find your way in your own
work. Thanks for joining me I'm excited to have
you here. And I'm excited to hear from you about
how working with data in a simple tool like Google
Sheets can help you find better value in your own
work. Before we really get started in this course,
there's one important piece of advice, I
always have to tell everybody. And that is,
when you're working with data, always do
pictures first. The idea is you want to
take a look at your data, see what's in front
of you get the context, get the big picture,
maybe zoom in on some smaller things, but you need
to start with a visual analysis. In other words,
first graphs, then numbers. As far as I'm
concerned, the graphs are the analysis, and
the numbers are simply a way of lending precision
to the numbers. I always tell my students when I
teach statistics, that every single thing we do in
the class can be done visually, you can graph it,
or you can calculate it with numbers as
possible to, but graphs and visuals come first.
Now, I can't talk about this without
sharing the world's best known example,
within the statistics community is called an
scums, quartet, statistician, Charles hands come
back in the 70s, somehow found a set of data
that did something very unusual. We have four
small set of data here. And what you need to see
is that these summary statistics on the bottom,
the sample size, the mean, that's the average, the
standard deviation, and measure of how spread out
things are the correlation between the two
variables. And the regression equation with
the slope and the intercept. See those numbers
right there, they're the same as those numbers,
right? There are the same as those numbers, right?
There are the same as those numbers right there.
So based on a cursory numerical analysis,
these four data sets are identical.
On the other hand, when you graph it,
you see, it doesn't really hold up.
Here's the first set of data, this is a nice
normal looking regression equation, things
are scattered around a little bit on this line.
This is what we're expecting in regular analysis.
On the other hand, the second pair of variables
has this really clear but curved relationship?
Now, the kind of analysis we usually
do is looking for straight lines,
because that's the simplest possible way of
describing an association between two things.
You can draw a straight line through this,
but you're doing damage to the relationship,
because really, you need to be modeling the
curve. There are ways to do that. But they're
relatively advanced. And I personally,
I've never had to deal with them.
The third set of variables, you see, we've got
this really strong straight line where we've got
one number, oop, that's popping up. And it's
an outlier. And the immediate question is,
what's going on with that number? Why is it
Adeline? Because if you're doing for instance,
a manufacturing process that might indicate
something's broken, it might just be a sensor,
that would be nice. But it could be something
about the manufacturing process. Again, our
standard approach doesn't deal well with outliers
and anomalies. And so you got to be careful about
that. And then the last one set for is a very
bizarre, really kind of a pathological data set,
where all of the numbers are jammed over here
on the left with this one extreme outlier on the
right, which would normally be an indication
that something has gone terribly, terribly
wrong in the data gathering. And so simply by
looking at them, you can see that there's an
enormous difference, even though, based on common
statistical measures, they were identical. Now,
these are artificial datasets, Charles anscombe,
had to work very hard to find these four sets
of data, but diverged so much graphically. But
closer to real life. There are other reasons why
you would want to do a graphical analysis first.
So for instance, take this, this is potential
data about donations to a nonprofit organization
by month. And you can see that on the left side,
things are motoring along kind of fine,
about 5000 bucks a month, great. And then
suddenly, halfway through it more than doubles,
and it settles down a little bit, then it goes
up another 10,000 and it settles down, then it
goes up another 10,000. And then it drops by 50%.
The graphical analysis, just a simple line
here, lets you know, we've got things going
on. And we need to figure out what's making
a jump up at each of these times, guys,
maybe we can do more of that. And then also
what making it drop off so much at the end.
This is the way that even a visual analysis
can guide the follow up questions and can guide
the actions that you take within your
organization as a way of better understanding
what's happening and allowing you to maximize your
effectiveness and your efficiency and reach Your
own goals. And besides, there's another thing,
people are very good at visual analysis. It's a
high information density medium. And so
by getting a picture by getting visuals,
you're going to get a lot more insight than
you could with simple tables of numbers.
So the moral of all of this is simply always start
by looking. Remember, begin with graphs, and then
follow them up with any numerical analysis that
you want to do. In doing so, you'll get a lot more
insight. And you'll avoid a lot more problems
on the way of getting to the information that
you need. If we're going to be on the same page
and understand what we're talking about in here,
we need to talk a little bit about the anatomy of
a spreadsheet. So the vocabulary that I use when
describing it can make some sense. First thing
is, the actual document that we're in, in Google
Sheets is just called a spreadsheet. In Microsoft
Excel is called a workbook. And a spreadsheet can
consist of more than one page, each of which has a
tab down here at the bottom. And Excel, these are
called worksheets. And then Google Sheets, they're
just called sheets. And that's where you actually
do your work. Now, each sheet consists of a number
of columns, vertical columns, that have letters to
indicate what column you're in, this is column D,
right here. And they have rows that are numbered,
row number one, row number two. And what that
means is that at the intersection of each column,
and each row is a cell. So right here, I've got
one cell, that's one box, one data container,
within a Google Sheet, that can put something
in it, and it has an address, this is cell
B, two. So you always give the column
name letter first, that's B in this case,
and the row number second, B to this here is C
three, this right here is B six, this is a four.
And so that's the address, you have cells that
make a spreadsheet that are arranged in vertical
columns and horizontal rows. Now, there's a lot
of other things you can do here. One thing is I
showed you, you can have multiple tabs. And those
allow you to have different kinds of information,
or arrange things in different ways on each one.
Each tab also has a little drop down arrow right
next to it that allows you to do things like
duplicate the tab or change the color of the tab.
There we go. Now we've got a little bit of color
right there, I'm going to turn that off actually.
Or to see a list of all the tabs, that's good,
if you've got a lot of them or to add a new tab,
add a sheet. And then when you come
up to the top of the spreadsheet,
Now a lot of times the first row is for the
names of the columns, the variable names,
and you might want that to stay where it is.
So if you scroll up, it doesn't disappear.
You can do that by freezing a row or you can
also freeze columns. And that means that they
will stay there. Now there's a few different ways
to do that. One of them is to come up here to view
and hit freeze and say the first row or the first
two rows or wherever I am right now, and columns,
I personally find it easier to come over here and
get this little thick line right here. And when it
turns into a hand, you just click on that and drag
it down. And now the thick lines right here, and
you can see that when I scroll up and down, that
first row will stay put, you can do the same thing
with columns. If you want, for instance, this
one to always show column A, just come over here
until you are have a little hand and then drag it
over. And now column A will always show and that's
called freezing rows and columns. And it's a way
of making it easier to navigate your spreadsheet.
Also, when you come up to the top here, you'll
find that you have a little drop down menu that
shows up in each of these, including the ability
to sort an entire sheet by values in a column.
So I can click this. And now it sorts the entire
sheet by this column right here. If I want to get
back to where I was, I could either do undo or I
could just come and sort by a different variable.
I sort by ID sort from ascending values from A to
Z, you can also sort descending that from Z to A.
You also have a number of toolbars. Up
here. Those are familiar with any other
program you've been using. There is one special
function I do want to draw to your attention.
And that is way down here in the bottom
corner. We have something that sometimes
called a quick sandbox, and what it is,
let me highlight a few numbers here.
I've highlighted some numbers. And now when
I come down here, you'll see it gives mean
the sum, I actually use this a lot. If I'm
putting in dollars, I'm putting in values,
I can get an immediate, somebody just dragging
over a few numbers and getting their total.
You can also click on it and see a whole lot of
other things, the average the minimum maximum,
the count the number of scores and the number of
numbers, there's only numbers here, so we're fine.
But that's a way to get immediate information
without even having to write a formula.
So the important thing is a spreadsheet
consists of individual sheets, or pages,
each of which has cells that are arranged into
vertical columns, which are named with letters,
and horizontal rows, which are named with numbers.
And as we go through the other videos, in this
course, you'll see there's a huge number of things
you can do within each document in Google Sheets.
More than anything, a spreadsheet,
like Google Sheets is a container
for data. And one of the important things to
remember is that data comes in lots of different
forms. A lot of it's numerically based, but even
then you can format it in many different ways.
And there is also non numeric data. And Google
Sheets can handle a huge amount of this. And I
want to show you some of those variations. So
you know what you can put in and adapt to your
own purposes. The most obvious one, of course, is
just plain old numbers, like this integer 1587,
you put those in there, Google Sheets will usually
put them flush, right text is usually flush left,
you can type those in, you can get a lot of
it is just those kinds of counting numbers.
On the other hand, you can also get proportions
which are red like percentages. So this is 0.87
is the same as 87%. In fact, if
you want to see it as a percentage,
you can just take that proportion, and you
can click here on the format is percent key,
there it is, it even gives you two
decimal places. But it's obviously 87%.
You also have the option of just typing
it in as 87%. I'll do it like this.
And that also works as a percent. If I press the
percent sign there, now you see how it works.
Now, there's one thing you don't want to
do, and that is type in the number 87.
And then think if you do this is going to
turn it into 87%, it turns it into 80 700%,
which is obviously not what you want.
So you need to start with a proportion,
the point eight, seven, and
it turns it into percentages.
You can also put in the number like pi and you
can decrease the decimals, which is good because
pi has infinite decimals. So it can make
a little smaller if you want. Or if you
have a number with a lot of decimals already
entered. And I'm using the PI function here,
you can increase the decimals, I don't know that
you really need a lot more, but they're available
if you want them. Now often the information you're
going to be entering into a spreadsheet is going
to be financial, you can have money, you're going
to be keeping track of purchases and payments.
And you have several different options. One is
the accounting format. So if you're an accountant,
you're familiar with this, but you come up
to format to number and then come down here
to accounting. And what it does is it puts the
comma in for the 1000, it puts the dollar sign
way over here. Okay, that's pretty easy. You
can also do financial formatting, which is
similar in certain ways, I'll come down here. And
you'll see it puts in the comma. But otherwise, it
doesn't have the dollar sign in it
formats a little bit differently.
And there's also currency. And you can
set your local currency in Google Sheets.
I'm going to use dollar, that's where I am. And so
you can see now it puts a little bit differently.
And it's three different ways of representing the
same information. Now, I realized they're slightly
different each other, it becomes a little more
pronounced when you make the numbers negative.
So I'm going to put a negative there. And now
you see it puts it in parentheses, that's a
common thing in accounting. And with financial, it
also puts it in parentheses. But when it comes to
currency, I put in a negative it sticks in front
of the dollar sign. So a few different ways of
dealing with money, depending on what's the most
common practice in the work that you do. You can
also put in dates, you just type them in seven
slash 16. It'll format them, and then I'll show
you in another video, there's a lot you can do
with dates in Google Sheets. And you can also use
time so for instance, 10 1031, just enter it as
hours and then colon, minutes, colon, and seconds.
So those are all numbers. And there's a lot of
things you can do with numbers. But Google Sheets
is able to handle a lot more than that it's able
to handle well. For instance, it can handle text,
so you can just type in words and it It turns out,
there's a lot of functions that allow you to deal
with words. And I'll give you examples of those
in a later movie. You can put in web links, if you
type in a valid web address, I just typed in data
lab.cc, my address, it recognizes that as HTTP,
although it should be HTTPS, because I have
an SSL certificate. And those are live links,
you can click on them, and it'll take you there.
So here, for instance, I have my website data lab
now opening because I had it here in the cell, the
same thing works, you can put email addresses in
there, it'll work a lot of different ways. You can
put web data, this is an interesting one, this is
a special function that calls in Google Finance
data. So this is today's stock price for Google
$1,066 a share. And by the way, notice that we get
this little disclaimer down here at the bottom,
if I were to delete that the disclaimer would
go away. Of course, you can use formulas,
and I've used a few of them already and have a
lot more say about formulas. So for instance,
the formula that pulls up this data is
Google Finance, and then in parentheses in
quotation marks at Google, because that's the
symbol for Google on financial markets. And
one other interesting thing you can do in Google
Sheets he can't do in every spreadsheet, is you
can include images. Now, this is an image that is
on the web, it's it's my company logo, and you do
image and then you put the URL for that image in
quotes. Nice thing is, if I make this cell bigger,
that you know it increases in size as well. So
you can put an image in a cell, if you can link
it from a URL, put that one back to where it was.
And then finally, you have the option of including
floating images and a number of other things. Let
me give you an example of that. I'm going to come
right here to insert, you can put in a chart, an
image, a drawing a form, checkboxes, columns, and
I'll talk about a lot of those. Let me just insert
an image for right now, the one thing you need to
know, when you include an image, I'm just gonna
get one off on my desktop, I got my data lab icon,
the one thing you need to know is that
it's a floating image. And so it's not
in the cell, you can drag it around, it's
also really big, I'm gonna make it smaller.
So it's not linked to this cell. And that's a
little different from this web image that we have
in the cell. But it is possible to include
this information, especially if you're
trying to build up a repository or even have
a sort of a branding with your spreadsheets,
it gives you many different options.
And so what you can see from all of
this is that Google Sheets is able to serve as a
container for a lot of different kinds of data,
each of which might arise in different
circumstances in your own work.
Once you have your data in Google Sheets, you have
a lot of options for how you format the data. Now,
this is mostly cosmetic in terms of changing the
appearance of the data. But it's also something
that can help you organize the data that makes
it much easier to follow the argument and bring
things to your attention. Let me give you some
of the really obvious things if you've ever used
a computer before, this is going to be familiar.
So first off is you get to change the font. The
default font in Google Sheets is Arial, which is
very clean, it works well in a lot of situations.
On the other hand, maybe you want a
different font, maybe you want something like
source meal goudy. That's one that I like.
And you come up here and you click on fonts,
and you go to source meal. And now you may not
have that because it's not installed by default.
If it's not, you just go to more font that takes
you to a web page and you can add a huge number of
fonts. Don't add all of them because then it gets
confusing, but find something that you need work
for your purposes. And you can add it in here and
it becomes available and it becomes available to
anybody who uses your document. Another option
is something like consolas if you're using
code, a fixed width font is pretty common. You
can change the font size so you can make it
smaller 10 point by default eight point is well,
I've got my screen zoomed in super big so it's
not too hard to see. It make a lot bigger. And
obviously this is something you might want to do
if you are putting in headings or titles. Now,
one thing to be aware of is you're not limited
to the choices that are here. So for instance,
I put 20 points, but I only had 24 points just
come up here, select the number and type
what you want. There's a 20 point font
you can also do the bold I got to do is do
Command or Control B, or you can click on that
same thing with a tallix. Just come
up here, you can do the other command
and strike through, I don't use strike through
very often, but it might be important for your
purposes. Okay, those are all quick and easy. The
next one is text color. Obviously, if you've used
a computer before you know how to do this stuff.
But color can be an important indicator of both
importance and directing focus. And that can be
really important when you're putting together
visualizations or making a table that you're
going to have to come back to and you need
help interpreted or you're sharing it with other
people. So I can come down and select the color,
there's red text, you can also do fill
color, that's an option. So if I do the fill,
it puts in the cell. Now, by the way, when you
have a dark fill like this, you usually want
to come and pick white text to go on top of
it. So it's easier to tell what's going on.
You can do cell borders, and I do these only
lightly, I tried to keep it pretty clean.
To do cell borders, select the cells that you
want to have borders on, and then come up to the
borders. And you know, you can put cells borders
on everything. But that's kind of a nightmare,
you don't want to do that. There are times I
have find, however, that it's nice to have just
horizontal lines going through the data, it's
relatively easy to direct the line across the
rows in a table, especially when it's printed.
I'm going to take that out for right now. But cell
borders are an option. row height, you can snap
it to fit or you can have a consistent size. Now,
snap to fit means something that happened
automatically here, you saw how that got bigger,
I can drag it down. So it's super huge, or I
can bring it back up. Either way, you saw when
I changed the font size, it automatically changed
the height of the row so that the text would fit.
Similar to that you have options for column width,
you can snap to fit or do a consistent size. This
actually requires a small
demonstration. So I'm going to put
three column headings here. And I'm going to
make them bold, because I often find it's helpful
to have column headings in bold, and they're
different sizes. If you want to snap to fit,
you can just select these three columns,
and then double click here on the right one.
And then it changes the width of each column so
that it adjusted the size of the text, there may
be situations in which you want to do that. On
the other hand, I find that having different
size columns can be a little disturbing. So you
can also do a consistent size. So for instance,
I can select all three of them here. And I can
make all of them the size of this last one. If
I just click this and drag it around a little and
I let go, now all of them will be the same size.
And that usually is easier to read because you
have this uniform movement across the document.
In addition to that, and maybe this is a solution,
you can do text alignment. Now all the text that
I've got right here so far, is flush left,
you can of course come over here and you can
center it, you can also make it flush right by
text is usually flush left, and that works best.
On the other hand, if you're doing a column,
you may want to have centered text for columns,
especially with the columns are different
sizes, that makes things a little easier,
you also have the option of changing vertical
alignment. But to make that clear, let me show you
one other thing. And that is text wrapping where
it says overflow wrap and clip. So let's make
this a little more obvious by making all of these
smaller, narrower. Okay, so you see how this one
that says extra extra extra long is now too big,
one of the options I have is to come right here
and to change it so that it is wrapped.
And that has it you know, go to two lines,
it is not breaking very well if I put
in a space here, it should break better.
Because it treats it as a single word. There we
go. Now it's breaking better. On the other hand,
maybe you want these other ones on the bottom,
but maybe you want to vertically orient them
towards the top towards the middle.
Anyhow, whatever works best for your
purposes. These are a lot of different ways that
you can format the document again, the point here
is not to noodle away your time and just kind of
mess with it because you can't, but the point of
it is to organize the document to make it clearer.
You want clarity and you want direction you want
to guide the eye through your document to make the
comprehension and analysis easier. And formatting
even with a small range of options is going to
make that a lot easier to Do in Google Sheets.
When you're getting ready to work with your data,
you'll find that your life becomes a lot easier
if you have tidy data. Now, this kind of a funny
term, but it actually refers to something specific
within the data science world, I want you to
know that if you go to Google and type in tiny
data, to the first three are going to take you
directly to the journal article in the Journal
of statistical software by Hadley Wickham, that
originally explained the idea of tidy data.
And you can also take you to a page on the our
project site that gives a lot more information
about what is meant by tidy data. The idea is
that data that is tidy is easier to manipulate
and is easier to take from one software package
to another. Now, this is where spreadsheets are
a little problematic, because spreadsheets are
amazingly flexible. And they allow you to do
a lot of things that might suit your purposes when
you're reading this spreadsheet, but they make
exporting or sharing with others kind of
a headache. So for instance, I've got a
spreadsheet right here, that does some of the
things that I hope you don't have to deal with.
First and foremost, we've got a problem here of
merged cells. This is when you take a single cell
and you spread it all the way across these other
ones sort of as a header, there's a merge cell,
there's a merge cell. This one is 15 cells
merged together, and it's smack in the middle of
everything. The problem with these is they change
the way the spreadsheet function. So for instance,
if I come here and click on column F, you
see it's selecting this entire first cell,
and then it's selecting all of this. But if I
then hit bold, it only changes this one. And if
I try to hit bowled back, it doesn't do anything I
have to do undo. And if I were to try to move it,
I'm just gonna come right here and
try to move it and hopes it just
doesn't want to work because of the merge cells.
merge cells are things that people sometimes do
to get title centered, but they make it really
difficult to work in the data. So you don't want
that. The other thing that you don't want is you
don't want to have mixed up labels, you don't want
to have things spread across in different tables,
that might work for an individual project. But
again, if you're planning on sharing it with other
people, or if there's the possibility, they might
take the data out of Google Sheets, and into some
statistical application or programming language,
they're going to need something else. Specifically
tidy data means that each column is the same thing
as a variable variables and columns are identical.
And that rows and observations are the same
thing. And so we need to get some of this
cleaned up. And so another thing you can see,
by the way, is with tidy data is that all of
the data needs to be in this spreadsheet. So
this is an important piece of information
potentially, but it needs to be in a column
to mark pieces. Also, we've got a comment kind of
hiding right here. And it tells us something that
maybe this person could be coded as being west
or an East depending on how we want to do it.
This is not the sort of thing you want to have
in a comment because if you export the data,
you'll lose all of that information. And so let's
take a few looks at how to tidy things up to make
them easier to work with and less problematic.
First one is get rid of all the merge cells,
get rid of those titles we had across the top.
And then the information that said the first 10
or surveyed in person, make a new column
and put that in there. So now we have
that information in this spreadsheet, it's not
included somewhere else, I decided not to make
a change for the comment because I didn't think
that was necessarily critical. If it were then
you might want to have two locations, starting
location and ending location for each person.
Now there's a couple of other problems. One is
that we have gender is coded in a crazy way we
don't even know what the zeros and ones are f&m
we can guess. And so we need to do a little bit
of data cleaning right now I'm going to come here
to this tab. And you see I've done two things.
Number one is I took the variable and I changed
his name from gender to female. Because when you
have a variable that you're going to treat as
dichotomous, it's really easiest if you use zero
for no a one for Yes, and you name the variable
by what the one is. In this case I decided to
assign female the one it's arbitrary, you can
do whichever one you want. But for anybody who
put down that they were female, I put a one for
anybody who put down they were male, I put a zero.
Similarly, for the method of surveying them, I
decided that if they got surveyed online, I would
give them a one and if it were anything else, like
in person, it would be zero. So I've cleaned that
up. But there's one more step that we need to do
and it has to do with this one right here. We've
got information hear about the location the person
is. And this is a different level of measurement,
everything else is at the individual level. This
is now about a larger group that they're in. And
we're repeating a lot of information. If you've
ever worked with a SQL database or a relational
database, you know that you set up separate
tables for different levels of measurement,
you want to do the same thing with tidy data.
So you keep information about the individual.
But then, if you have this information at a
different level, that's repeated, you put that
into a separate table, it's just a tiny little
table. And then we only have to indicate whether
a person's location was north, east, south or
west, we can get the rest of this information
from this table. And when you do those things,
what you'll end up with ultimately is two
separate sheets, you'll have one sheet that
contains all the individual level information,
where each column is a variable, each row
is an observation and all of the relevant
information is put into those variables
and columns. And you'll have a second sheet
that contains the variables for the other level of
measurement. Now, again, this is mostly important
if you're going to be exporting your data so it
can be analyzed in a nother program. If you're
working entirely within Google Sheets, it's
never going somewhere else. You might be okay,
doing whatever you want. Just be aware that
the flexibility that you get with spreadsheets
gives you a lot of room for creativity, but it
can potentially create some headaches. And so
when in doubt, take the tidy data approach, keep
your data clean and make it easy to work with
easy to analyze and easy to get meaning out of
your analytical life becomes much simpler and much
faster if you're able to collaborate with
other people. And fortunately, that's one of
the things that Google Sheets does best. To share
a document to share a spreadsheet with somebody,
all you need to do is come up to click on
the blue Share button. And there's a lot of
different ways you can share with people. Now
the most direct, it's just simply put in their
email address right here. Here's a fake email
address that I just got data@superego.com. And
you have the option of assigning different
levels of sharing that that person actually
can change the document, they can edit it, or
they can simply make comments on it, but they
can't change the actual text. Or they can simply
view it. And you can say, here is the document.
And it will email that person and let them know
that they've got the document and then they get
into it and they can start working on it with you.
You also have the option of sharing with a link.
So for instance, you can say that anybody at
your organization if you have a Google business
account, or you can click on More here, you can
share anybody who has a link or public on the web,
which is what I've done on this one. And I've set
it so that anybody who has the link can view it,
I could set it up so they could comment or
edit but view is gonna work best in this case,
I hit save. And then as long as
people have this very long link,
but you click Copy Link, and I'm going to open
up a new incognito window, click it like this.
And now this is the way that anybody can see it,
they can see the document, they can't change it,
it's given me a little blurb about updates here.
Here says View only, that's fine. But you can see
that other people this is my professional account
with data lab, this is my personal account.
And even though this person can edit it, they
can download it as a Microsoft Excel file or a
CSV or CSV file, and they can start working
on it themselves. I'm gonna close this one.
Now one of the nice things about the way that
sharing works in Google Docs, I'm gonna just
delete this one, I don't really want to share
with my fake email address, I'm gonna press cancel
and done. But when you're sharing, you can see
who's sharing right here. That's my personal
account. This is my company account. And you're
able to see where they are in the document. So for
instance, I'm going to be in this cell right
here. But I can tell that the other person
is surrounded in pink same as we have up here
is in this cell. And if I go to that account,
you can see I have the document open. That's
where I am, you can see that I'm now sharing with
my company account. And it's a good way to see
who's working on it where they are, and to start
collaborating to get your analysis up and running
as fast as possible. sharing an individual sheet
within Google Sheets may accomplish your purposes.
But often you're going to work with people on more
than one thing or there's more than one resource
you need to share. And in that case, rather than
sharing each of them individually, it's a
lot easier in Google Drive to share a folder
to do that All you need to do is come to the
folder that you want to share, and you get it
selected. And you can either come up here to
get a shareable link, you can click on this
to go share it, or you can, for instance, option,
click on it right here and do share. And then
you're going to add the person you want to share
it with, you can put in a specific email address,
and then with that include a message to them. Or
you can get a link that you can share with people,
you got a lot of different choices here.
I personally haven't said that anybody
on the web could actually search for this, they
can searchable on Google and get it or they
have a specific link. Lots of other ways. And you
also have the option of whether they can view it,
see the contents, or whether they can organize
add an edit information within each of these. Now,
right now I have it set to just view. And let's
see, well, if you're looking at these files,
you know how it works. But I'm gonna copy the
link. And I'm gonna open up an incognito window.
So I'm not logged into this one. And I'll enter
that link and go to it. And what you have here
are the three different files, I've got a little
icon file, you can look at that one, it's just a
little data lab icon. I've got an empty document
that says we're sharing this, this is where it
shared. And I've got the spreadsheet that I'm
working on right now. And when I open this one,
it gives us this little advertisement lets us
know that new things are coming, you can see who's
logged into it, that's my personal account. That's
my company account. And although you can only view
it here, you do have the option of downloading
the file just as you did when we were sharing
individual files. The nice thing, of course, is
anything that anybody puts into the folder is
automatically shared with everybody else who has
access to it. And when you're working on a project
with more than one step in it, say for instance,
you have a presentation, you have a report,
you have several different files that build
up to it, sharing a folder is going to be
faster and more efficient and more effective
way of collaborating within Google Sheets.
If you're going to work with data, you have to
have some data and you have to have it in Google
Sheets. Now, the fundamental way to do this is to
enter the data directly into Google Sheets. And
there's a lot of times where that's the preferable
solution. If you're going to be working with a
statistical program, like SPSS or SAS, it's so
much easier to put it into a spreadsheet, there's
a lot of advantages to it. One is it's really
easy to share and have several people working
simultaneously on what you're doing here. Now, I
want to show you if you're going to be entering
data manually, and say Francis is going to be
entering it based on paper surveys that you have,
there's a few things you want to do to make your
life a little easy. First off, you want to have
what's called tidy data. That's a term developed
by Hadley Wickham, who works with the statistical
programming language R. And it means that a
variable is the same thing as a column. And that
a case is the same thing as row. And there's just
no funny business going on in your sheet. So let's
start with this one. If you're entering paper, the
first thing you need to do is have an ID number
so that you can find that piece of paper in case
something gets entered wrong. Now, you may need to
get out a pen and write these numbers on a piece
of paper. And then maybe you start putting in the
questions. Now I want to show you something kind
of neat that Google Sheets and Microsoft Excel are
able to do and what that is, is propagating.
So if you take a pattern as easy to follow.
So for instance, I like to type q 01, where q is
for question, and then do q 02. For Question two
minute, I'm not doing q1 q2, cuz it's gonna think
that means quarter, one, quarter, two in the year.
But if I do the leading zeros, especially
if there's more than nine questions, this is
important, I can select those first two, and then
I can just drag them over. And it will propagate
and fill in with the same pattern. You can do that
for however many you have. And then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take this top column, I'm
going to put it in bold, and maybe I will even
center the columns you don't have to and there's
a there is a precedent for text columns being
justified to the left and numbers
being justified to the right, you know,
it's up to you. Sometimes I just like to do this
so that the labels are directly above the numbers,
it's a little easier to see what's going
on. And then I'm going to freeze the top row
by simply dragging this bar down. And now when
you scroll up and down, that top row stays put.
If you're going to be entering data from pieces
of paper, like I said you need ID numbers and
so you go like this 123 and it can propagate that
same pattern. So I'll drag it down a little bit.
And now we've got the numbers as long as
those match up with what's on your paper,
you're good to go. If several people are entering
the data, then you might want to be able to
separate who has what. And the first person might
start with 101. And then one or two. So the one,
the first 100 indicates the person, the second
number indicates which one they're working on.
And then the next person can start with 201,
and 202. It's okay that there are gaps that you
go straight from 107 to 201, you just can't have
repeats, that's the important thing. And this way,
people can be working separately on their own
computers, and they can be entering the data
simultaneously in the same sheet. And it
gets in there, it's wonderful. And so the
very simple method for entering this is to type
in a number, let's say you've got a rating scale,
and people are putting in a number. And then I
hit tab, go to the next one, or a right arrow, and
nine, and I can go through and enter like this.
I'm just hitting tab at each point, when I get
to the end, I hit return. And it takes me back
to where I started on the first line. And I can
go on like this, I can type in the data however I
want. If you have missing data, if a person didn't
answer a question is it best to simply leave it
blank. And then if they typed in something you
can put in eight, although I would hope that they
didn't type in something on what's supposed to be
a numerical variable. But the idea here is you can
put in whatever you want, and you enter the data
all the way through. And now you have entered
your data manually. And you're prepared to do
subsequent analyses. Although it's possible for
you to enter all your data in manually in Google
sheets or another spreadsheet. And again, there
may be situations where you need to do that,
life is so much easier if you can simply import
the data and dump it in there and get going. Now,
what I want to show you is slightly different
from importing a file into Google Drive the
place that stores files. So for instance, you can
take an Excel file, drag it into Google Drive,
and you can store it in either the native Excel
format or converted to a Google Sheets document, I
actually want to show you how to import something
straight into a sheet in an existing Google Sheet.
And to do this, we're simply going to go up
to File and then come down here to import.
And when you do that, it's going to ask you
to import something I'm going to go to upload
and select a file from my computer that
actually, let me show you what I have here.
I have three files here that are identical except
for their format. They're all called import. And
they're just data files that have an ID number, a
date, or response ID five rating scale questions
in a zip code, it's this is made up data. This is
in Excel as an XLS x spreadsheet. This over here
is the same data in a CSV or comma separated value
spreadsheet. And this one in the middle here is a
text document, but they're still separated
by tabs. So it's identical information in
all of them. So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to come back to Google Sheets.
And I'm going to select one of these files. I'm
just going to take the import dot CSV, I'm going
to hit open. And then it's going to bring up a
little dialog box and ask me some questions about
what I want to do. Do I want to create a totally
new spreadsheet? No, I don't even want to insert a
new sheet, I want to replace the current sheet. So
it's the sheet that I already have the information
on, put it there. And if I want to tell it what
the separator is a tab, comma, or whatever,
but it can detect it automatically. And
I'm using comma separated values. So it's
it's easy to deal with, and then convert text
and numbers and dates. Yes. And I hit import
takes just a second. And here it is, it's in my
new sheet. And so I've got my data, all the rows
and the columns are intact. If I want to make my
life a little easier. I'll freeze the top row.
And maybe I will come here, maybe
I'll select the whole thing.
And make it all flush, right. Except for
these two, which I'll put then back to
flush left. And my data sets ready to go. And now
I can start analyzing. So importing directly into
an existing Google Sheet very quick and easy
way to get up and running with Google Sheets.
I have an untested theory that the single most
common container for data sets in the entire world
is spreadsheets. And of those I think the
majority are probably going to be Microsoft Excel
spreadsheets. So for instance, if somebody sends
you a spreadsheet or if you download a spreadsheet
from online, it might be an Excel format. And even
though it's really easy to import Excel directly
into Google Drive or into Google Sheets, I do
want to show you you also can just resort to
plain ol cop Paste. So I've got a spreadsheet
here, that's import, and it's the same data
I've been using for some other examples. I'm
going to select the entire set by doing shift
and then command or control with space, I get the
rectangle, I'm going to hit copy, and then just
go back to excel sheets and hit paste, I'm going
to do Ctrl or Command V in this case, and there's
my data I'm ready to go. On the other hand, it
may be that you also are going to be using data
from web pages on tables. I do this occasionally.
And so for instance, if we go to this next tab,
I have a link here to a page in Wikipedia on Nobel
laureates that has a table in it. So let's open
this page. And it talks about who's won the Nobel
Prize, which is a wonderful thing to do. And here
we have a table with a list of everybody who has
ever won a Nobel prize from 1901, down through
2017. There we go. Now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to copy this, I
find it works best if I start at the bottom
right, and I just click and I drag up.
And I'm gonna go up to 1901,
there's have to not go past it,
almost there. And I'm going to copy the headings
too. So now I let go, I've got that all selected,
I do Command or Ctrl C to copy it. Then
I'm going to go back to my spreadsheet.
I'm going to come to this cell right here. And all
I do is I hit Command or Control V to paste it in.
Now this is going to do something slightly weird.
And that is, these are all links. So I've got a
million links in this table. And truthfully, that
may cause problems as I'm trying to deal with the
data. So I'm actually going to ask Google Sheets
to not paste it as links. But to paste as plain
text, I do that by coming to this little clipboard
that pops up when you first pay something.
And I say give me the values only. And now
you see it just turns into unformatted text.
And that's a great way to go. I can then
if I want to I can delete this first row.
I can then lock that first
row, I can put it in bold.
I can highlight the columns and then just
double click right here to resize them.
And now I've got a data set that
I can work with. This is great.
I do want to show you one tiny more little trick
about copying and pasting. In Excel, I'm going to
go to this sheet called paste transpose. And I'm
just going to type in a little bit of data here.
Now, I showed you in another video how Google
Sheets is able to fill in a pattern. And if you do
123, it just keeps continuing. If you do q 01 or
q 02. It can also do this with things like days of
the week. So I've got Sunday, Monday here. And I'm
just gonna highlight those two. And I'll drag it
down a little bit. And look we have now have the
whole week. Now what I want to show you, if you
want to switch it from being arranged vertically
in a column to being the column headers,
what you want to do is a special kind of paste
called A transpose or transposition. So I'm going
to copy this by hitting Ctrl or Command C, that'll
just come over here. And I'm going to do a Ctrl,
click, it's actually a two finger, click on
my trackpad, and go to paste special. And
we've got a few options here. The one I want to
show is this one right here, paste transpose,
and it flips it around from the rows to the
columns. And if you're trying to set up your data
for analysis, this can save you a lot of stress
about trying to rearrange things manually. So
that's just one final tip on getting data by copy
and paste into Google Sheets. When you're working
with data, one of the truisms is that about 80% of
the time is spent simply getting the data ready.
And when you're working in Google Sheets, you got
a few things that can help you get the data ready,
especially in terms of keeping notes for yourself
and communicating with others. In this video,
I want to show you how to make notes which are a
little different from comments which I'm going to
show you another time. A note is something
that you put in a cell that is an addition
to that cell. So for instance, let's try this.
In this page. I've got three different sets of
data. I've got days of the week, I've got months
of the year and I've got a series of odd numbers.
There are a couple of mistakes in this one. So
for instance, we have June appears twice here.
One possibility is to make a note here, I can
either right click on That's a two finger click.
And I can insert a note. Or I can
come up to the menu here and do insert
note. And what I'm going to
say is, June, appears twice.
When I click away from that, you can
see that we've got this little box here,
this little corner. And if I hover over the cell,
then the note appears. Now the only trick is,
somebody has to actually be on the sheet to know
that that's there, I'll go to my other account
where I'm sharing this. And you can see that
that note now appears, it doesn't say who did it,
it's just a note that's in the cell. Now, some
people unfortunately, try to put actual data
there stuff that you need to know to interpret
it, please don't ever do that. This is something
that can be there temporarily in terms of drawing
attention to something, even though it's not very
effective at drawing, but adding a little more
context to what you have in the cell. Now, a more
effective way is to actually make a comment, which
is what I want to show you in the next video.
When you're collaborating with others on your
data, you want to be able to communicate back
and forth. And sometimes the best way is to put
comments on specific cells within a spreadsheet.
Now, you can do notes, which I showed you
previously. But those are just kind of passive,
and they're there, they don't draw attention
to themselves and not attributed to anybody.
And they're really not as helpful as an actual
comment. Let me show you how this is going to
work, I'm going to highlight two errors in this
spreadsheet. One is I have the month in June
twice. Now to insert a comment, I can do a few
different things, I can come up here to insert.
Or I can use the keyboard shortcut, which
can be a little different on Macintosh,
which is what I'm using and Windows computers.
Or you can also right click on it or option,
click on it and come down to insert comment.
That's what I'm going to do right now.
And then you see that it brings up who's making
the comment and this is my personal account. And
then it's going to say, why is this repeated.
And then I can do Command or Control Enter or
to hit the comment. And so that's that rephrase.
And so that's now there. Now let's go to the other
account to see what it looks like in the
discussion. And you're at this highlights
that there's a comment there. So it's drawing
attention to itself in the way that a note didn't.
And it lets me know who's asking the question.
And I can then click on this. And say, because
June was so good, we wanted it twice. And I can
click on reply. And now we're both in this thread.
And then I can come down here Oh look, it
brings up my whole google plus profile.
And if you want to bring in somebody else, you
could click on this, you could say for instance,
let's put data at sample Comm. I don't
think that's a real email address.
What do you think? And this is a way of bringing
in additional people to the conversation inviting
them and highlight in the comment for them,
I'm actually going to send this because that's
not a real email address, I'm gonna hit Cancel to
discard the comment. But the comment is there and
you can ask for information, you can propose
a resolution. And when you finally come around
to it, you can go like this, you can say,
well, let's fix it. Let's do July. And then
we've now resolved it. So we can hit resolve. And
it hides the discussion it archives it. And so
that is now done, I can go to the
other account to see what's happened.
And you can see that the comment
notification is gone, the comment is gone.
And it's fixed. And so this is a really good
way of drawing attention to things that need
repairing, and then making the action, I'll just
highlight that we have one other right here.
And I'll insert another comment. This
should not be here. It's not odd.
Anyhow, that's something you can do for future
reference as a way of communicating with others.
And it makes organizing the data and getting
ready for your analysis a lot easier within
Google Sheets. When you're collaborating with
other people. Sometimes it's sufficient to
put notes into the document or to have the
common feature which invites a discussion,
but that's asynchronous, it's not in real
time. On the other hand, there are different
times when having a real time conversation is
going to get you a lot further a lot faster in
your work. Fortunately, Google Sheets makes that
kind of conversation really easy with a built in
chat. functionality. To do that, you have to have
at least two people working on the same document,
I can come over here and I can see that I've
got it open in my other account. And then I
click on this icon, which says show chat. And
then I simply come down to the chat window,
type Hello. And then lets me know I've sent them
a message. Now let me go to the other account.
And it's telling me that there's a
message here. Now, if I click on this,
it just kind of goes away. But if I come up
here, where I've got my little notification
dot, I open up the chat,
and there it is. Here I am.
What's up. And now I've got this conversation
going back and forth. And this allows people
to work together in a way to try to solve the
issues, it works really well when people are
really far apart. And maybe for instance, a live
telephone conversation is not the best idea.
This chat history stays there, as long as anybody
has the document open. So for instance, let me go
to my other account. And I will close the document
here. And then once you get over here is an
indication that Barton Paulson, that's my other
account has left. If I close the document here,
and then I open it right back
up. I give it a moment to load.
And there's actually nothing there because the
other person is not even in there anymore. So the
chat history disappears once everybody closes the
document. But while you're there, it's a great way
to have this real time conversation about what's
happening in the document, what tasks needs to be
done, how to interpret and how to apply your
insights, certain skills seems so basic that
they don't really seem worth discussing. But it
turns out that knowing some of the special tricks
can make your life a lot easier. This applies
to Google Sheets as it applies to so many other
things. And what I want to show you in terms of
basic skills is simply how to select data and move
it around. Now, obviously, if you want to select
just one cell, you get your cursor and you click
on that cell, and you can move it around by doing
the arrows here and driving it around with the
arrows that's left in one cell. That's easy. If
you want to select a column, just come and click
on the letter above that column. And you've got
the entire thing. If you want select more than
one column, click and drag across. Now you've
got columns. And the same thing works for rows,
just click on the row number. Can you select
the entire row, you can select several rows as
well by clicking and dragging. So that's easy.
If you want to select the entire spreadsheet,
come up here and click on this area that's
to the top left. And that selects everything
every single cell in the entire spreadsheet. Let's
come back up to here. Let's say I want to select
just this first row. Now actually, to make this
easier, I'm going to maximize my screen so you
can see the entire data set, I'm first going to
go fullscreen on my Mac and then I'm going to hide
these controls right here. And so now you can see,
I've got a data set with an empty column right
here and I've got an empty row right here, that's
going to affect how some of this stuff works.
Now, let me come up to here, I'll just stick
the cursor right here. If I want to select an
entire column, I can do it with the keyboard by
doing Ctrl and space. And you see what it does
is it selects vertically, until it thinks
it has reached the end of the data.
And it thinks it's reached the end because
I've got this big empty row right here,
so it ignores it. On the other hand, if that
row were not empty, let's say I put an X there.
And I were to give this a title up here, I'll
call that x also. Now it's going to unite the
whole data set, I'm going to come back over to
here, I'll hit control and space, and nicea slugs
down to the bottom because now it sees this
all in one unified whole, even though there
are gaps in it. So Ctrl Space selects the entire
current column. I'll do Ctrl Space right here.
And if I want to expand my selection, I can
do shift and then use an arrow, right arrow or
left arrow to get more of what I want. There's
a similar command for selecting rows. So let
me just hit escape. I'll actually I'll just
click right here. And I'll do shift space.
And what this does is it selects the entire row
in the data rectangle. If I want to expand that,
I can use the down arrow or I can use the up
arrow. And that is a way of selecting data,
sometimes a little more precisely
than dragging through with a cursor.
One other thing that you want to know is about
moving data. So say for instance, I want to move
this score. So it's on the other side of
category, what I do is you see how I selected
it. Now when I come up here, I have a hand, if I
just click and drag over, I switched him around,
I'll put it back by undoing that move. That's
really easy. I do this same thing right here.
I'll expand that, I can click and just drag
down my data and move it to a new position.
And this can be an important way of fixing the way
that you've entered things, you can sort things
manually with an ID number. But in terms of
rearranging variables, the click and drag is by
far the easiest way to go. And so the ability
to click on individual cells and then expand
my doing shift and the arrows, or to select
rows and columns within the data rectangle,
by doing Ctrl. N space, or shift and space are
great ways to grab the data you need and perform
the functions you want. It's a small thing, and
again, doesn't always seem worth mentioning. But
it can make your life much quicker and less
error prone when working in Google Sheets.
One of the most important things you can do
for making sense of your data is to first get
it sorted, put it in order, because a spreadsheet
allows you to do something called Data browsing.
And is to actually look at the data that's in
front of you, again, is sounds like a fundamental
thing, but it makes a really big difference.
Fortunately, this is really easy to do in Google
Sheets. And you need to be aware this works a
little differently than it does in Microsoft
Excel. Because when there are gaps in Excel,
sometimes things don't sort the way you expected,
you can actually terminally mess up the data. But
in Google Sheets, it's really easy. Now what I
have is a small data set here with an ID number.
And I have a random number, they got descending
letters and categories and so on. Here's all you
have to do to sort come here to the top in this
little sea, watch how this little arrow shows
up, you click on that. And then you can sort
a to z which means ascending or Z to A which is
descending, you can actually randomize it, too.
So now I've sorted it descending based on this
random number. If you want to sort it by more than
one category, what you need to do is to sort it by
the last one until the big one. So for instance,
I might want to have this category over here, I
can show you what it looks like when it's sorted.
I've got some fours and some ones. By the way,
what it's doing is it's sorting alphabetically,
not in terms of meaning. But let's say I wanted to
have these numbers sorted within these categories,
the scores. So what I have to do is
I have to start with the last one.
So I'm going to come to score. And I'm going
to sort this sheet in ascending values.
And then I come next to category. And I sort
it by ascending values. And now within four,
I've got my 123 and three. And so this way, I
can have a first sort of second sort. But again,
you have to do it kind of in a backwards
method. But anyhow, it's a very quick and
easy way to get things under control. Also, one
of the reasons I mentioned earlier as as really
important to have an ID row a column that
gives an ID number is because it makes it
possible to get back your original order,
I'm just going to sort this ascending.
And then right back to where I was to begin with.
Sometimes you only need to deal with some of your
data, you don't need to see everybody but you
need to see cases that meet specific criteria.
Google Sheets allows you to do this very easily
with filtering. What you do is when you have
your data in front of you is you come over and you
click on this icon over here, which is the filter.
And when you click that, it selects the data
table, it was the column headers and the row
headers in green. And you get these little
filter icons. Now, you can do a couple of
different things with these. You can select text,
you can select scores, you can create formulas,
I'll show you a two step selection for the
filter. So we can find cases that meet particular
criteria. So for instance, let me come over
here to category let's say, I only want to see
category one and three, I can deselect these
other two or you can do it the other way you
can clear them all and then select just
the ones that you want Either one works.
So one and three and I click that and you see
it, the other ones are filtered out now and
then if I want to do a nother layer on top of
that, for instance, I can come here to score
and I can say I only want to see Cases whose
score is above a certain value. Now I could
select them manually because you only have a few
choices here. But I can also come up to filter by
condition. And I've got a lot of different choices
here with text and date. And values, I'm gonna say
greater than not greater than or equal to, but
greater than. And I'm going to put in a three.
And when I click that, the other
cases are filtered out. And so now,
whereas I originally had 19 lines of data,
I'm now down to a much smaller number. Now,
it's kind of hard to tell because it's hiding the
row numbers of the cases that were filtered out.
But now I only have the six cases that meet my two
criteria of being in either category one or three,
and having a score greater than three. And so
this allows me to find particular cases, say,
for instance, people who have made over a certain
number of purchases or open requests, or people
who've been involved an unusually high amount with
your organization. This allows you to find those
particular cases, and give them the attention that
they deserve. When you're trying to sort through
your data and filter out cases that needs special
attention, you have the option of either doing
what I call ad hoc filters, which are the ones
you get when you simply click on the filter icon.
And it brings up a menu like this. But you also
have the option of doing what are called filter
views, which stay with the data and you can have
multiple filter views. Let me show you how these
are a little different. I'm going to click on
new filter view, you have to click on the arrow
to get those. And then you see the window looks
a little different. We got this black bar here,
and the column headers and row headers are in
black. But let's do a filter view. Now what I'm
going to do here is let's say let's get the
first 10 cases, I'm going to come over here,
click on this filter for ID. And then I'm
going to say filter by condition where the
value is less than or equal to 10.
Okay, when I get that I hit OK.
And there we have it and see by the way
that the rows Now jump from 11 to 20.
But what's interesting is I can save this filter,
I come up here to where it says name says filter
one, I just highlight that, and I replace
that with let's call it the first 10 cases.
And so now, that's a saved filter. And if I come
over to here, and click on this little side arrow,
you can see it saved right there. Now let's
go to none. So it undoes that one. And let's
create another filter view, I'm going to
come and click on this right arrow again,
say new filter view. And let's replicate a filter
I did with the other example on regular filtering,
let's come to category and select just
the one and three. So there's that one,
and then let's select scores that are
greater than three. So greater than three.
Alright, and now I've got those cases. And
I can come over here and name that one as
category one and three, score greater than
three. And so that is saved as a filter to.
So when I come back here, I have both of those
available to me, and the ability to turn it all
off. So if I want to go see just the first
10 cases, I click like this, I get those.
If I want my compound selection, I click like
this. And it's different. And if I want to have
the entire data set, I simply click none. And
all of these are useful. I use it all the time
when I have to find cases that have not yet been
resolved, and allows me to see the open cases.
And I just select down to those unable to focus
on them exclusively. So it's a wonderful way to
save the view into your data and also to be
able to share it with others. And so that,
again, allows you to soar through your data focus
on the particular cases that are most important
and get your analysis done. You may get to a point
in your analyses where you don't want to work
with just specific collaborators, but you actually
want to get out to everybody. Google Sheets allows
you to publish your both your spreadsheet and
your results to the entire Worldwide Web. This is
different from sharing via link where people can
actually log in and potentially make changes to
your folder. This is actually where you can post
it as a web page or as a downloadable Excel file
or a PDF. And well it makes the most sense to do
this with individual graphics, which you can embed
in a web page. I want to show you how this works
in general. What you need to do is come up to
File and then come down to publish to the web.
And when you click on that you get a few different
choices. You can publish the entire document,
or you can publish one of the tabs out of it.
I'll do the entire document for right now. But
you may have more specific needs. And also,
you can publish it as a web page, in which case,
it'll show up as an HTML web page. Or you can
do any of these other formats, in which case,
it will simply initiate an automatic download
of the file. So you don't see anything there.
Just go straight to your download folder.
Let me show you what this looks like.
I'm going to publish the entire thing,
I'm going to hit Publish. It says Do I want
to publish it? Yes, because you don't want to
do this stuff by accident. And now I've got this
big long web address, I'm going to copy that and
go to a private browser, I'm going to open it
up. And now you can see now it's not the most
attractive or well formatted. But that's because
it's a web page and not the actual spreadsheet.
Because I published the entire spreadsheet, I have
all of these different tabs that are available as
hyperlink selections. And so this is one way
of sharing things. Now, again, this works
better if it's graphics that you're sharing,
especially if they're interactive graphics.
I don't have an example of those later. But
this is one way to get things out and about.
The other option, by the way, aside from linking
is to embed the information into a website,
like a WordPress site, or Squarespace or your own
website. And then you can include the data there.
So that is already hosted in house for people,
they don't have to go to the link directly,
but it's right there in front of them. And any
of those methods will allow you to get your data
out and your message out to as wide an audience
as possible. The last thing I want to say about
sharing files and sharing your work is of course
that sometimes things go wrong. Sometimes you
put stuff in you accidentally delete something,
or formulas get mixed up at some way long. And
there are problems. And you may want to be able
to backup the work that you did. Fortunately,
this is really, really simple in Google Sheets,
because it has a built in version history. To get
to this, all you need to do is come to file,
and down to version history. Now one of the
interesting things is that you have an option of
naming the current version, you can say draft one,
draft two or clients review or whatever. But
let's come here and see the version history.
When I click on that, it's going to show me
all the different changes that have been made.
Now these ones I mean, if you click open on
them, you're going to see a lot more things.
And two things, you have the option saying show
me only the named version. So I have draft one
and the final version, which are my named ones.
And then you also have the option saying show
the changes. So if I unclick that, it simply shows
you the plain document, if you click Show changes,
it lets you know that all of this got added
and it got added by this person in this color,
the teal Barton pulse and founder RF we
back up a little more, you can see draft
one. And you can see for instance, that there was
information that got added. I think here in notes,
you see the number of tabs changes,
and that this is all new for this one.
And so this is an option to hit restore this
version, go back in time to the one you had,
before things got out of hand, you can recover
from any mistake in Google Sheets, you can also
create these different versions that allow you to
have a sort of version control. So you don't have
to be a fancy person using GitHub, or subversion
or something like that. You can use the built in
version history in Google Sheets to keep track
of your work to recover from errors and see who's
contributed what, it's a great way of getting
accountability and getting recoverability.
The first graph I want to show you isn't
even technically, Google Sheets graph,
it's a hack. It uses a function called repeat to
make a bar chart, and it puts it in a cell which
actually is really convenient and makes a
lot of other things possible. Let me show
you how this works. What I have here is a made
up data of the number of social media followers,
a person might have on several different
platforms, Facebook, Twitter, and so on.
And I've counted the number of people. Now you can
also do this if you have means averages, and you
put the number in there. But let's just see how we
do this. I want to make a column called chart. And
then I'm going to type in equals because I'm using
a function and our E p t, which stands for repeat.
Now, when you use the repeat function, the first
thing it wants to know is what is it going to
repeat what's it going to put in many times and
you have to put it in quotes. I'm going to do
the quote and then the vertical pipe that's
on the US keyboard is above the return key.
And then you tell it how many times you want
it. And that's where I refer over to this cell.
And you can see it's giving you a preview
of it right there, I'm going to close the
formula with the closing parenthesis, hit return.
And now I've got 50 pipes, all adjust that,
that show an indication of how many people you
have following you on Facebook. What's neat about
this is because it's a formula, I can just drag
this down like this. And now I've got a for each
one of my cells. And so it's really easy to see
that we got about twice as many people here as
we have here. And that's about twice as many as
we have here. It's also really flexible. If you
want to draw attention to one particular category,
say for instance, you're interested in Instagram,
you can just highlight that row. And
for instance, you can change its color.
And now you've got a bar that matches the
color you've put things in. So this is a way
to make it easy to find what you're looking
for and focus, especially if you have a lot of
different categories you're looking at. Plus, this
is a flexible procedure. Let me just copy this and
paste it down here. Now what we're getting
is five more pipes, but you can put anything
other than pipes. So for instance, I got a little
emoji here, smiley face with eyes, I'm going to
copy that, I'm going to come back over to this.
And instead of the pipe, I'm going to do Smiley's.
And so now you got a graphic, you can use any
emoji you want positive, negative, funny ones. But
it lets you get a very quick visualization. And
it's a great way to start looking at your data.
The single most useful chart that you can make is
a bar chart for showing a quantity by category,
either the number of people in a group, or an
average for that group. And this is really easy
to do in Google Sheets. Here I have a table. This
shows the frequencies for a number of social media
followers in each platform. And all I have to do
is select one of these cells, I got it up here
in the top, and I come over to Insert Chart. And
Google Sheets is smart enough to know that I want
a bar chart by default. Now you can see here, if
I click on suggested it gives me a few choices.
But this is the bar chart really quick and easy.
There's a few things I would want to do to modify
this first, I'm actually going to move it over a
little bit. So it's not overlapping with my data.
Instead of saying count versus social media
followers, I'm going to change the title.
I just clicked on that. And I'm going to put by
platform. I'm going to get rid of this legend here
because it doesn't tell me anything useful. So I
click on that, double click, and then I put none.
I'm going to change this word over here from count
to followers. And then I don't think I need
this here on the bottom. So I'm just going to
select that and then delete it. And then finally,
I think I'm going to change the color of the bars,
I'm going to double click on the bars, pick a
different color. I personally like this red.
And so there's an excellent bar chart. Now
I will mention one funny thing. Technically,
this isn't a bar chart, it's a column chart,
because it's vertical. A bar chart goes sideways.
And so let's take a quick look at how we can make
it a bar chart. I'm going to copy this chart,
and then paste it. And then
I'll drag this down a little.
So I can put it underneath. I'll scroll up now.
And all I need to do is double click on this
chart, and then come over and tell it I no longer
want a column chart, I want a bar chart. Now I'm
gonna have to clean things up, it went back to the
default title. So I'm going to change it again to
BI platform. And I'm going to delete this again.
And I need to clean this up again. But the reason
this is a good chart, the sideways bar chart is
because if you have long labels now the words
Facebook, Twitter and Instagram are not long.
But if they were longer than this makes it easier
to read them because you don't have to turn your
head sideways or something and it puts it
in the same orientation as the bar itself,
so it's easier to follow through with it in a
logical manner. Anyhow, this is the simplest
chart you can make a bar chart a column chart
and truthfully 90% of the time it's going to
give you all the information you need to
make the conclusions based on your data.
A recent development in Google Sheets is a way
that makes it even easier to create bar charts.
Now in another video, I showed you how to create
bar charts using a table where you summarize
the number of cases you have in each category.
But Google Sheets is also able to do this with
raw data. So here, we just have a list of a whole
bunch of followers. We have Pinterest, Facebook,
Facebook, so on and so forth, we can scroll down,
you can see they're all kind of jumbled in there.
But we don't even have to count them. All I
need to do is come over to this insert, chart,
click on that. And it creates a bar chart,
it counts it all by itself. Now, I'm going to
still do a couple of things here to clean this
one up. I'm going to change the title here.
So that it says social media followers
by platform, I'm going to get rid of this
legend because it's not helpful
and takes up a lot of space.
I need to change this over here to say just
say followers on the vertical axis. And on the
horizontal axis, I don't need that title at all.
So I'm going to just delete that. And there you
have it, you got a bar chart quick and easy. Now
the only major qualification on this one is that
you see the bars are out of order. What they are
is they're in the order that each category first
appears in the data. So you can see the very first
one is Pinterest. The second one is Facebook,
then we scroll down a little bit, we get
Twitter. And you can't modify that. And so that's
one small problem. But it still makes
it really easy to see that most of the
followers are from Facebook, the least or from
medium. And it lets you start getting insights
in your data without even having to do the
Data Prep of putting it in the table first.
If you want to look at the relationship between
two different variables, or two different outcomes
and how they affect your results, a grouped
bar chart can be a really good way to do this.
So here I have the same social media followers
data I have had before. And now I've labeled the
data we've had previously as subscribers,
and I've added a new column for visitors,
you might be able to tell these apart and get
separate reports in your analytic software.
But let's see how we can show each of these. And
what's interesting is this is where Google Sheets
gives us a few important alternatives. I'm just
going to select this first cell here, come over to
Insert Chart. And once again, it's nice
that Google Sheets is smart enough to
select the entire table of data and it gives it
a good title. And what we have here is a side
by side chart. Now I'm going to make just a few
changes here. I'm going to put again, here by
platform. And although in other examples, I've
gotten rid of the legend, the legend is important
in this one because you can see that blue means
subscribers and red mean visitors. On the other
hand, with a vertical column chart like this where
things are side by side, having the legend off to
the right isn't really helpful, because you got to
go back and forth to look. So I'm going to click
on this. And instead of having it on the right,
I'm going to put it on the bottom. And now you
can see that we have the blue on the left the red
on the right, and it's the same orientation as our
other data. I'm going to get rid of this because
it's just taking up space, and we don't need that.
And now it's a little bit closer. And then I am
going to add one other thing, we don't have an
vertical axis here, I'm going to add that one
vertical axis title. And I'll put followers
okay. And so this is a basic side by side chart,
and we can get from this is that we've got a lot
of subscribers in Facebook, we got more there
than any other platform. And we've got a lot
of visitors on Facebook, but also Instagram and
a ton on Pinterest. By the way, this is totally
made up data. But you see a different pattern on
LinkedIn where it's a small number, but we have
more subscribers and visitors. Again, this is made
up your situation may be completely different. But
I want to show you two other ways of arranging
a grouped bar chart that gives you different
kinds of insight. Maybe you're not so concerned
about whether a person's a visitor or subscriber,
but whether they simply come to your site and
follow you at all. In that case, you can rearrange
the chart by stacking the blue and the red. Here's
how you would do it. I'm going to copy this chart
and paste it here. I'm going to scroll get
this drag it down a little bit and then get it.
So this is a simple copy of what we had before.
But I'm going to double click on it. And this
time I'm going to come to this option under data.
This is stacking. Right now it says none because
things are right next to each other. They're not
stacked at all but if I do standard stacking,
now it puts the one on top of the other And
you can still see that, you know, we've got
more subscribers in Facebook than anything
else, we got a lot of visitors on Pinterest.
But overall, you can see we're getting
the most visits from Pinterest,
the second most from Facebook, the third most
from Instagram. And so you can combine them to
get a total, this can be really, really helpful.
And in this case, you might actually want to put
the legend back on the right, because you
want to have things arranged top and bottom.
And so now we have visitors on top subscribers.
And that might be a better way to do it.
Now there's one other option. And the deal is,
it's hard to compare proportions with this when
you're able to look at absolute frequencies.
But maybe you want to look at percentages of
visitors who are subscribers versus regular
visitors. And so we have one more option with a
grouped bar chart, I'm going to copy this chart,
paste it in, and I won't bring it down here.
We'll scroll up, I'm actually going to
make a couple of changes on this one,
the first thing I'm going to do, bring it
up just a little more. And I'm actually
gonna change the chart type. Now right now
it's a stacked column chart. But again,
sometimes a bar chart, which is the horizontal
left to right chart might be a better choice.
What I'm going to do here first is I'm going to
change the kind of stacking instead of standard,
I'm going to go to what's called 100%, where
it gives us not the frequencies of accounts,
but the proportions of people. And now for
instance, you see that LinkedIn becomes huge in
terms of the number of subscribers, if we go back
to standard for a second, you can see that there's
only a small number of people visiting from
LinkedIn in my artificial data. But the proportion
who are subscribers is huge compared to the
others. And the proportion or subscribers is
very small, in my Pinterest data, just 10.2%. Now
I want to show you one other thing you can do, I'm
going to delete this one, and we don't need that
at all. And I'm going to put a horizontal axis
title to say proportions of followers,
because remember, point two, five means 25%.
point five means 50%, and so on, I'm probably
going to put the legend back on the bottom.
And then I'm just going to change the
colors because I can, I'm going to come
in here and click on the red. And I'm going
to change it to say for instance, a gray here.
It's a little prettier to look at. But these are
three variations on group bar charts, they're
showing you both the platform of persons on and
they're showing you whether they're a subscriber
or visitor. And they give you different insights,
one allows you to look at the absolute frequencies
next to each other. The second one lets you look
at the totals. And the third one lets you look
at the proportions. All of them are valid, all of
them give different perspectives on your data. And
any of that can be used to help you plan what your
next step should be in your social media campaign.
Most people when they think of spreadsheets,
they think of Microsoft Excel and Google
Sheets is very similar to excel, a lot
of the functions carry straight over.
But there are some differences part of it, because
it's actually a web sheet that gives a lot more
functionality in that respect. But some things
don't operate quite the way you would think.
If you want to make a bar chart and make
one of the bars a different color. In Excel,
all you got to do is click on that bar and
manually change its color. But in Google Sheets,
you have to do it differently. Say for instance, I
don't have my data here on social media followers,
and I want to draw attention to Instagram.
Well, it turns out that the way to make
Instagrams bar a different color than the others
is to actually make a group bar chart. What I'm
gonna do is I'm going to create a second column
here, I'll call it, highlight. And then I'm going
to take Instagrams value, and I'm going to move
it over. So this is kind of a funny data because
no platform has values in both of these columns.
They're in either one or the other. But watch how
this works. I come to social media followers. And
I click Insert Chart, and it makes it by default,
a group to barter but it's a really funny looking
one because everything's half width is expecting
information from each of the columns. But if we
come over here to stacking, and we change it to
standard, then we suddenly have what we want.
There's a couple of things I want to change,
however that I think are important number one is
I want to get rid of this legend it's actually
creates confusion. So we get rid of that and we
need a real title social media iidea followers by
platform. And then I can delete this one here on
the bottom by just deleting this text over here.
And now we've got a simple bar chart, column chart
actually, where we are able to draw attention to
one particular category Instagram, by putting a
value in a different column and making a stacked
bar chart, it's a funny way to have to go about
it. But it still lets you get to the same goal of
making a clear visualization and drawing attention
to the important values. Another way of showing
the number of cases or observations in a category,
in addition to bar charts, is with pie charts.
Now, I have to mention, there's a lot of people in
the data visualization world who get very upset at
the mere mention of pie charts. But I want to
point out, there's a few reasons in which pie
charts are actually a good choice. Number one
is, if you're required by your work to use them,
if you have a template, and they use pie
charts, that's what you got to use. Second,
there actually is some evidence to say that
certain groups of people find pie charts easier
to read than bar charts, especially if you're
talking about allotment of time during the day.
Third, there are some times where a pie chart
actually can be easy to read, especially if you're
only trying to show one number a percentage.
But let me give you a few examples here.
I'm going to take the social media followers data,
and I'm going to come over and click on the Insert
Chart now. By default, Google Sheets makes a good
choice and creates a bar chart. But we're going to
make things a little different. Now you'll notice
by the way, that I change the order of things
I put Instagram first. That's because in other
examples, I wanted to draw attention to Instagram.
But if you're going to have one particular
category you want to focus on in a pie chart,
it should be the first one, that means it'll
start at 12 o'clock, and it'll be the one that
leads off the impressions. So what I'm going to
do is I'm going to come back here to chart type.
And you can see we have right here, a suggested
type is a pie chart. And this is the default
pie chart or the beach ball or the pinwheel. And
you know, it's not horrible how it is I'm going
to change a few things. I'm going to change this
title here. Social media, followers, my platform.
And then I'm going to make one other thing where
I put some information here and the slice is now
the way I do that is by coming over to pie chart.
And I'm going to say slice label, each of these
segments is a slice, you say label. Now,
I realized that what I just put in here
is redundant because it says Instagram here and
it says Instagram here too. And unfortunately,
I can't control what is displayed
right here. That's the hard part.
But I'm going to show you a couple of things
we can do about that. On the other hand,
I want to point out these labels. First
off, because the medium size is small,
the word medium didn't show up. And Twitter is
shown in a different color, which under certain
circumstances might be a good idea, but it's a
little weird in this one, I'm going to fix that
by coming here, again to pie chart. And I'm
going to make the labels a little smaller.
I think if I go to 14, nope, I gotta go
smaller still, to 12 point there, then
they're all inside. And I can also change their
color, I'm just going to make them all white.
So now it's a little more uniform. And it's a
little easier to read and Instagram, you can
see the one I want to talk about is right here
at the very beginning. That's nice. But I want
to show you an easier way to draw attention
to what you want and to avoid some of the
optic, no overwhelm of a pie chart. So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to copy this chart,
and you copy and paste it and I'll
make a copy on drag it down here.
And what I'm going to do them is several things,
but the single most important one is I'm going
to change the chart type. Now there are two ways
to do this. If we were to come back to data here,
and you see chart, it says pie chart that
let me show you if you scroll down here,
you can see there are three variations on the
pie chart. There's this standard pie chart,
there's a donut chart, and that's
actually the one we're going to use.
But I'm going to show you there's another
way to get to that. And then there's the
3d pie chart which is lean back, which actually is
a horrible thing for data visualization because it
actually distorts the data harder to read. Just
don't ever use that. But I can get a donut chart
by clicking this one or I can come back
to customize and you may have noticed this
option early The donut hole right now to 0%. I
can make it 25%. So it's a little donut hole,
I can make it bigger 50, I can make it bigger
still, you can enter in any number you want.
50% seems to work well for a lot of purposes,
especially if you still want labels in there. Now,
I'm going to make a few other choices, I'm
going to come back up here to chart style.
And I'm going to do kind of a fun one here,
which is maximize. And that gets rid of the
title and it makes the chart as big as it can
be. Then I'm going to come down to legend.
That's these things right here, Facebook, 31.3%,
Instagram 16.3%, I'm just gonna get rid of that.
So now I just have this colorful donut. I'm going
to change the colors of each of these, because I
want to draw attention to Instagram. So I'm going
to click on that. And you have to change each of
these manually. But I can do it pretty quickly.
I'm going to make all the ones that I don't want
to emphasize a uniform gray, there's a gray that's
right above the bright green seems to work well.
So all of them get to be that great except
for the Instagram, which I want to emphasize.
Now there's one major problem here. And that is
you can't tell where the slices start or stop,
it's really hard to tell. So I'm
going to click back on these,
I'm going to come back up to pie chart and do a
border color. And the border color I'm going to
use is going to be a lighter shade of Gray's say
maybe this one right here. It's not much, but it
makes it possible to tell a part of the slices.
And so this is a good step. It's a wait to see
that Instagram is about one six, in fact,
at 16.3%. And you can see how it compares
to the others. Now there's one thing that I
personally like to do, in addition to this,
and I usually do this in presentation software.
So if I'm doing this in Google Slides, I'll add a
little piece in there. But it can be done here in
Google Sheets as well, I'm going to add a number
that says how big this is as a percentage. Now, if
we come back up here, you'll see that it's 16.3%.
That's good. What I'm going to do is I'm going to
bring this up, and I'm going to insert a drawing
is kind of a funny way to do it. But it
works, you know, it's a little bit of a hack,
I'm going to insert a text box,
I'm going to type in the number
16%. And then I'm going to make it
a pretty font, I'll use a garamond.
And then I'm going to make it much larger,
I'm going to bring it up to 48 point,
I can make that box a little smaller, I hit Save
and Close. And then it's over here floating on
the side. But I can just click on that. drag it
over and sort of eyeball to position it in here.
And now what you have is you got a number in
the doughnut hole that says exactly how big
the one highlighted pieces. And it makes
it really easy to read. And so this is a
situation where I actually think that pie charts
or really their relative the donut chart can make
it easier to present a kind of information and
can give better clarity to your presentation.
When you have a quantitative or measured variable,
like the price of an order, or the amount of time
somebody spent on your website, or the number of
kids in a family, you want to make a histogram
as a way of looking at the overall shape of
the distribution. It helps you see if there's
any spikes in particular places helps to see if
there's gaps in outliers. So let's take a look at
some artificial data I have here on hypothetical
orders or totals from particular clients. And
we've got a bunch of rows of data here 113. But
let's just come over and click on Insert Chart.
One of the things is Google Sheets, again, is
smart and is able to figure out that a histogram
would be most appropriate for this. There's
a few things that we need to change. However,
I need to click on this and get rid of the legend
because it's just silly and taking up space.
And what you can see is that most of the orders
are down here low it's drawing a box that goes
from $0 to $1,650. Next one to $3,300. By the way,
the width of these boxes, the fact that it goes to
1650, then 3300. That's called the bucket width
or bandwidth. And it's arbitrary. You can make
it as small as you want as big as you want. What
Google Sheets is doing is it's using a rule of
thumb that says you usually somewhere around seven
911 bars is best. And so it's dividing the data up
to do that. And you can see, we've got one case,
way up here, and we got this big gap here in the
middle. This is a skewed distribution, which is
actually what you expect anytime you're dealing
with something like money. And we've got this
one big outlier. Now, when you have an outlier,
like this, the first thing you want to do is
see is that data correct. And if it is correct,
then you get to decide what you want to include
it in. It may be, for instance, that because it's
so unusual, it represents a different category,
you don't want to include it with the others.
But let me show you a couple of things
you can do to help clean up a histogram.
To help decide what's going on with your
data. I'm going to double click on this.
And well, since it brought me to this one,
I'm just going to change the color because I
prefer that color. But let me come back up to
histogram, you can change the bucket size. Now
it's doing buckets at $1,650 each, which I think
is silly. So I'm going to manually change them to
$1,000 each. And well, it does introduce a lot
more empty space here. It's easier to read them,
I'm going to change these values here and not have
them slanted. slanted is really hard to read, I'm
just going to make them straight up vertical. At
least it's easier to tell what's going on there.
And so this is one way of looking at it, we still
have this big outlier, we got this huge gap. But
it lets us know where most of our cases are. Now
Google Sheets does give you one option for dealing
with outliers. Of course, you could just exclude
it from the data say this is not representative
of the group that we're wanting to deal with.
Or you could use a different kind of analysis.
But there is one option. So I'm going to double
click on this coming to the histogram. And as
this one right here, it's outlier percentile.
And what this does is it takes the highest
certain percent of cases, and it brings them
down and puts them in the next lowest bar. So
watch what happens when I do this. Right. Now
we've got this one case up here, we got this
huge gap. And then the next highest is at 5000.
So if I click this 1%, boom, it brings it way
down. Now what it's also done, unfortunately, is
it's changed the way it draws the bands and labels
and it gives them these really weird arbitrary
cutoff points. And unfortunately, there's really
not much you can do about that, you know, you can
try going down to horizontal axis and manually
setting the value to zero. But once you've done
the binning thing, it doesn't have any effect.
But it still lets you see the pictures that most
of our cases are down here, then we got this,
we got this little gap here, then we got a couple
of cases that are higher, you could do a higher
percentage, if you want it, you could do for
instance 5%. And you see it changes a little
bit more. But you're never gonna get rid of these
weird bins down here. So the only way to get rid
of those, by the way is to just back up and do the
Undo and undo, undo. And now you're back to where
you were originally. But the important thing here
is that Google Sheets is able to draw a histogram
by default, you're able to see that most of
your order totals are in the 1000 or 2000 range.
And then you got this really huge gap with this
one extremely high total up here more than three
times as high as anybody else. But this is the
purpose of a histogram to help you find these
generalities where most of the orders are, and the
outliers, exceptions. And so this gives you a good
start on trying to make sense of your orders. And
what you want to do next in your business. One of
the most important things you can look at in an
organization is change over time. That might be
the number of customers you have the number of
people you reach the amount of money you bring
in. There's a lot of different things. And one
of the best ways of looking at that is with a
line graph, where you have time across the
bottom and the quantity that you're looking at,
measured vertically. Now I'm going to show you
how to do both a single line graph and a multiple
line graph. What I have here is a made up data
of revenue from several different sources for a
nonprofit organization. So we have donations, we
have events that they run for, say for instance,
ticket sales, we have grants that they receive
from private or government organizations, and
the total amount of revenue for each month. And
I've only got it for about a year and a half here.
But this is enough to show us how these kinds of
graphs work and the value you can get out of them.
I'm going to start by doing just donations,
although I do have to select a month
also because that's what goes across the
bottom. So I'm selecting these two columns.
And I come over and I hit Insert Chart. And
it does a line graph by default and so you
can see that things are kind of flat here at
the beginning then they There's a big jump.
And by the way, if you just hover over, it can
tell you what the actual value is already each
point. But there's a few things that would be
important to modify in this graph. First off, is
I'm going to put not donations versus month that
makes it sound like there's an opposition, but
donations by month. And then we
don't need this legend over here,
because there's only one line doesn't tell
us anything useful. So I'm going to hit none.
And then I'm going to make a couple of
other modifications to this chart. One is I
don't like you know, the jagged line. So I'm
going to change its color, I'm going to change its
thickness, I find a thicker line is often easier
to deal with the four points seems to work well.
And then I'm going to put points on to indicate
the actual values, the observations. So you see,
now we have a point at each place, that's
helpful. Another thing you can do is I'm
going to scroll back up to the top here to
chart style, is I have an option to smooth the
line, because right now it goes
straight bend, straight bend. And
I think that the jagged parts draw too much
attention to themselves. So by smoothing it out,
we make it curved, and it's a little
easier to see the pattern over time.
Now, just as a note, there is a separate smooth
line chart as a type. So you can choose that if
you want. But since I was just using the automatic
insert, chart, customizing that seemed like a good
way to go. The next thing I want to fix is this
over here, we've got 5000 10,000 15,000. It's
easy to read. But the 1000s parse takes up more
space, and I want so I'm going to click on that.
And I'm going to come here to the vertical axis to
this scale factor. And when I hit 1000, it divide
all these numbers by 1000. But I need to make sure
that we don't think we're receiving just $10 in
donations. So I'm going to modify this vertical
axis title. And then in parentheses, I'll put
1000s. And then there's one more thing I want to
do here. And that is right down at the bottom,
it's giving me some of the months and you know,
maybe that's okay. But personally, I'd like to
see all of them. And so all I had to do is click
on that and come to this one under horizontal
axis and say treat labels as text. And when I do
that, it shows all of them. On the other hand,
it also slammed some which is hard to read.
So I'm going to change that to 90 degrees.
And then I don't think we need this title here
anymore for the access because it's explanatory
what it is. And so there is a very clear line
chart that shows the variations in donations
by month from October of 2016 to February of
2018, it's really easy to see the changes, you
want to see what happened between here and here to
cause this big spike, what happened to get it all
the way up to this maximum, and why did it fall so
quickly. And so those are some of the issues that
you're going to want to look at. But fortunately,
this is what the purpose of this visualization is,
is to bring these things to your attention, so
you can investigate it. Now, I showed you the
beginning, there's more than one source of revenue
for this organization. There's not just donations,
there's also events, there's grants, and there's
a total, we can get all of those into one chart,
show you how that works, when I'm going to
do is I'm going to make a copy of this chart.
So now I'm going to take this new
chart, I'm going to drag it down,
move things up, but not all the way I want to
keep a little bit of the data showing over here,
because I need to change the data that
I'm using. So I'm going to click on this
and do edit chart, then I'm going to hit data
range. And when I do that, I can simply come
over to the data. If I do shift command space
on a Mac, or shift control space on a PC selects
the entire block of data. I hit that and voila,
there's all my data. Now I'm going to come up
and I'm going to make some changes to this.
I'm going to come over here and I'm going to
select all series, and I'm going to do all of
them four pixels thick and all of them was seven
pixel dots. Now, because I changed
this red one manually, that means this
darker orange one sort of conflicts
and so I need to change its
color. So I'm going to come here to
the darker orange one, which is events.
And I'm going to change it to a blue. Great,
so now we can tell them apart a little better.
Now there's a couple of other things I need to do
because I changed the nature of the data. Number
one is I need to change the title here because
this is no longer just donations. I need to put
revenue by Source by month. And then here
on the side, I need to change donations to
revenue. There we go. And there's one other thing.
Because I have several different lines, you need
to know which is which. And so I need to put the
legend back in. So I'm going to put a legend, and
then I'm going to put it on the, well, let's see
how it looks on the right, there's on the right.
And there is on the bottom. I actually
think that maybe in this case, the one
on the bottom looks a little bit better,
because we get a little more linearity
in the chart that we have going across. In any
case, this is a way of looking at the change over
time of several different values. And it lets you
see how the multiple sources contribute to a total
and gives you a better picture, in this case,
the financial health of your organization.
If you want to show changes over time, you do
have the option of doing the basic line chart
which I've showed elsewhere. But Google Sheets
also gives you a specialized timeline, which is
designed for things that have months or years
on the bottom. And a change in quantity,
often financial over time. I'm going to use the
same data here, and I'm going to show you how to
make this specialized timeline. I'll start with
just the first two columns month and donations.
And when I click on the Insert Chart, it's
going to give us the default timeline,
which we've had before. But I'm going to come
here to chart type. And I'm going to click that
and go way down to the bottom where we have
the timeline chart. And when I click on that,
it's a different kind of thing, it actually
gives you some interactive functionality. Now
I'm going to do a couple of things first, just
to clean it up, and come here to customize.
And I'm going to change the line thickness
from one to four. So the lines thicker.
And I'm going to give it Fill Opacity, just 10%
which fills in the area beneath it, and it makes
it a little easier to see what's going on. There's
one other important thing, you'll see that these
values here go from 5000 to 10,000 to 15,000.
But they don't start at zero. And in my mind,
they should always start at zero. So I'm going
to click on this box expand range to show zero.
And now we're setting that's as many
options as I have for this. But what
I want to show you is that when you come over
here, you see as I go over a particular value,
it will highlight that value, and give us the
date and the amount, you can control it two
different ways. Number one is you can come down
here and you can drag this box to set your own
time range. That's, you know, that's the whole
point of having the timeline. Or you can use these
zoom buttons, you can say go back to the max,
show me the last year show me the last six months.
If you've ever worked with financial data on
the web, you often have these same options.
Now, this is a simple timeline, with
just one variable being displayed,
we can do more than that. In fact, I'm going to
come back here and I'm going to copy this chart.
Let me drag that new copied
chart down, not overlapping.
And what I'm going to do in this
chart is I'm going to change
the data that it uses. And I'm going to give it
all of the data, I'm going to come back up here,
just click in here and do this Shift Ctrl or
Command and spacebar that selects the data.
And now I've got all of it there. And there's
really nothing else I need to do because it
maintains all the same options that I
already set. But you know, we can still
do the interactive thing, we can click right here,
we can come back a little bit. And as I come in,
you see how it says donations, events,
grants and total up here at the top.
As I come into the chart, it'll give us the actual
values of each of those as we scroll through. And
so that is a great way to explore the data and
to see what's happening there as well. And so the
timeline chart, well, it has fewer options overall
gives you some very specific functions that are
hard to assemble on your own, but give you the
ability to explore your data in more detail.
Changes in spreadsheet graphics may come
slowly, but they do come and one of the more
interesting developments in data visualization
in spreadsheets, and especially in Google Sheets,
is something called a sparkline. Now, this
is a concept that derives from work by
Edward tufte. He really father of modern data
visualization. But the idea here is to create
a very small graphic that fits in line with text.
And in the case of spreadsheets, it means it fits
right in a cell. What I'm going to show you is how
to make these in cell visualizations for several
different kinds of data because this sparkline
function in Google Sheets is pretty Be flexible.
Now, this is a formula. So I type equals, and
then I start typing in sparkline. And you can
see it says it's gonna give me a miniature chart
within a single cell, I just need to tell it
what data I so I highlight this data, and then
I close the parenthesis. And then there it is,
I now have a timeline chart, it's really
small. I'll make it bigger for right now.
Let's scroll down a little. And so now I've
got this little timeline chart that shows the
variation in donations over time, it sets
it so that the lowest values at the bottom,
the highest values here at the top, and
it just moves over one step at a time,
it doesn't indicate months, it's just going from
this cell to this cell to this cell. But here's
the neat thing, because it's a formula, I can do
what I do with other formulas, and I can drag it
to apply to other columns. And so now I've
got this little timeline for each one of them.
This is really a marvelous thing, when
you've got a bunch of different data sources,
you want to look at them really quickly.
Also, because they're in each cell,
you know, I can just make the cell bigger
if I want to, and now the charts are bigger.
Also, you have the option of changing some of the
properties of each sparkline. So for instance,
this one right here, it looks like it goes
from really low to really high. But if you
scroll through the data, you see that
it actually goes from 12,000 to 20,000.
So it's a little misleading to have it start
that low, we can change, where it starts by
fixing a parameter called y min. So I'm going to
double click on this. And I come right here. And
I'm going to paste in a comma, and then in curly
brackets, because that's how you do arguments in
Google sheets for sparklines. I put in quotes,
why man, that's the thing, I want to change,
comma, and then the value I want it to have,
I enter. And now you can see it's bumped up
so that it's a little over halfway up. That's
a big improvement over what we had, you can
change other things as well, you can change
for instance, the color and the line thickness,
which I'll do with this one, this is our total,
so it should appear a little bit differently.
I'm going to put in there, two arguments, one, I'm
going to change the color. And this is a hex code,
it's a way of specifying colors is frequently
used with computers. This is the dark red that
I've been using in lots of other things, then I
put a semicolon, because I'm going to include a
second argument, that is line width and two means
two pixels. And now I've got a total chart, which
is stands apart from the others, but also lets us
see the change in time. And so this is a really
handy way to look at data. And the flexibility,
being able to do it in Excel is a fabulous thing.
Now I'm going to come over, I'm going to
put this back down for a moment to 100%,
I'm going to come over to this next column is
called win loss. Now you may not be doing this
in your data. This originally comes from Sports
about whether a team won a game or lost a game.
And then putting in some zeros indicate that
they didn't play or there was a rain out or
something like that. You can adapt this to other
things like for instance, whether you got a new
client where they lost a client, I don't know,
whatever works well for you, I'm going to come
down here and I'm going to put in another
sparkline. I'm just gonna do a sparkline.
And I'm going to select the data. Now if I just do
this, by default, it'll draw the same kind of line
graph that I have over in the others. And that
might be helpful. But with wind loss data, there's
a special kind of sparklines, I'm going to open
up that one. And I'm going to insert this extra
information, where it's a chart type is when loss
all one word here. And when I do that, it gives
me this little collection of bars on the top half
and on the bottom half. Let me zoom in on those.
I'll go back to 200. scroll over a little bit,
come down here. And so you can see we start with
two wins, we got a couple of rain outs and then
a loss a win a few losses. And it's a way of
seeing this pattern of a dichotomous variable.
Over time, you can do things like you can put
different colors for the tops and for the bottom,
you can put a line through the middle. And you
can there's a lot of options for coloring this.
But this is the default win loss chart. Now I
want to come and finish with one other one.
I'm going to back this down to maybe 150.
And that is the social media follower data that
I've used before. I did this with a repeat chart,
which allowed me to draw just vertical bars using
a formula all the way across. There is a way to do
this with sparklines. But it takes a little bit of
adaptation. So let me do this. Enter sparkline and
then I'll tell it the thing I'm going to draw
is this I'm going to close it print Now I'm
going to get an error message. And the reason
I'm going to get an error is because it says
you need at least two data points, and I only gave
it one. But I'm doing a different kind of data. So
what I'm going to do is I'm going to double click
on this. And then right here, I'm going to insert
that I'm doing a bar chart. So I put comma, and
then in curly brackets, chart type, comma, bar.
And when I do that, it draws a bar that fills up
the whole cell, that's actually kind of neat. And
I can drag it down. But you'll see there's another
problem here, it just automatically assumes that
each bar should go to the maximum. So right now,
it's not telling us anything, what I have to do
is I have to change the maximum on each of these,
so that each one of these bars has as its maximum,
the maximum value here in our account, which is
this 50. So I'm going to double click on this one,
I'm going to come right here, and
I'm going to insert another argument.
Now when I'm putting is max is equal to the
maximum of this range of data and I have to
use the dollar sign to and dollar sign seven,
so that it always stays at row two to row seven,
as I drag the formula down. Now the first
part is not going to look any different.
But as I drag it down, now you see that all the
other ones adjust, they show you what proportion,
they are of the maximum score of 50. So
sparklines are really creative and new way
of visualizing several different kinds of data,
changes over time, wins and losses over time,
even simple bar charts, but all done within
cells, which allow you to rearrange them in a
number of ways, they've got a lot of other
options, you can explore some of those.
But this is an really fun development in data
visualization in Google Sheets, wouldn't you like
to be able to predict the future or at least try
to guess how things are going to happen very soon.
One way to do this is with using scatter plots
and associations between two quantitative or
scaled variables. In this example, I'm looking at
the number of sales in quarter one and the number
of sales in quarter two of these are totally
made up numbers. But I want to show you how
to build a scatterplot and get some predictive
value out of it. Now when I take these data,
and I just click on Insert Chart, by default, it
gives me the two line charts, which is definitely
not what I want. I want to see how they connect
one with another. So I click here on chart type.
And one of the suggested charts is a scatterplot.
And this lets you see the connection between
sales in quarter one and sales and quarter to
sale. For instance, we got one quarter here,
that was really low in quarter one, it's about
a 90, but super high in quarter two. So things
went better. What are the others, it was just
kind of uniform, that quarter two seem to be
pretty consistent. Now I do want to show you
a couple of ways to modify these charts that
might make it work better for your presentations.
The first of these is that I'm going to come in
and I'm going to change just for instance,
the colors, I'm going to change it to red.
And then I'm going to take this option right here
and add a trendline. What this is, is a straight
line that goes through data that summarizes the
relationship between the two. And because we've
got this really unusual score over here, that's
super low on X and super high on y, we end up with
an downhill pattern overall, I can make that a
little thicker if I want to make it to four point.
And you can change the color and the opacity. But
I'm gonna do one other thing here, it's gonna say
show r squared. Now, this is a little more
than I really want to do when I'm talking
about visualization, because this is getting into
actual data analysis. But this is a statistical
measure of the strength of association between
two variables, it goes from zero to one and
you read it like a proportion. So the fact that
this one says trend line for sales, and it says
r squared equals 0.091. That tells you that 9% of
the variance in quarter two sales can be accounted
for by the variance in quarter one sales. It's
a technical thing, but it lets you know there's
an association there, but it's small, I'm going to
do one other thing and then call it quits on this.
I'm going to come back to this trendline. But
I'm gonna go to series because what I want to do
is I simply want to change the title for this,
it gives custom labeled trendline for q2 sales,
I'm just going to remove that. So we just
have the R squared there. And then that
is a good final chart for looking at
the association between two variables.
If you're familiar with scatter plots, and if you
understand how regression works, then this is the
best way to look at the association between two
quantitative variables. You can repeat it for lots
of different possible associations to find the
variables that can give you the best predictive
insight into what's out happening in your
organization. If you want to draw a scatterplot,
to show the association between two quantitative
variables, but you want to draw attention
to one of the observations, you want to,
for instance, change its color. Again,
in other programs, this might be easy to do, just
click on the dot change it. But in Google Sheets,
as we saw with bar charts, if you want to change a
bar, you got to do it in kind of a funny way. The
way it works here is again, we create a new column
for the one data point that we want to highlight.
So what I'm going to do here is I'm going to have
our q1 and q2 sales, let's say that we have a new
channel, a new method of making sales,
and we want to highlight that one,
I'm going to come down here to this 116, because
I know this is an unusual score. And I cut it out
of there and paste it over here. And now you
see we've got this one value sitting in this
column all by itself. Let me highlight all of this
data, just doing the shift command or control in
the spacebar, and then come over to Insert
Chart. Now what it does is it gives me these
three bar charts, which is definitely not what
I want, I'm going to come down to scatterplot.
And now when I move this over, you can see
that the one unusual value is here, all by
itself Way up high. And that accentuates it.
So we can see that something else is going on
with this particular data set. Now another
option I have here is to draw a trend line.
And it does the trend line for the collection
of the data. And you can see that you know, it's
really kind of flat all the way through. And that
highlights that it's really consistent from q1 to
q2, except for this one special new channel that
has been massively productive in getting us sales
in the second quarter. So again, it's a little
bit of a hack. But if you want to highlight the
one of them in Google Sheets, you're going to
need to put that value into a separate column,
you only need to put one of the values for it into
a separate column. And that will allow you to put
it in a different color and draw attention
to it. An important thing to remember about
Google Sheets is that it's made by Google. And
so it's not just a software company. This is
a very serious Ted company with a very high end
machine learning and even artificial intelligence.
And they have found ways to bring this into Google
Sheets. And so I thought I'd end this chapter by
doing something that kind of pulls the rug out
from under a lot of the other work I did, by
showing you the automatic graphs you can get from
a new feature in Google Sheets called explore.
If you look way down in the bottom right, you
will see a green button here that says explore.
And it shows up in several different programs.
It'll show up in Docs, it'll show up in
slides. But hearing cheats, it does something
in particular, I'm going to click on explore.
You can also do the Option Shift x, and it brings
up this window on the right. And it allows you
to ask for instance, like what's the correlation
between events and donations, these two different
sources. And look, it'll give you a scatterplot.
It'll even give you a formula. And you can get
this information a lot of these directly from
right here. You can format the document if
you want to do it in shades of green look, now
it will do it for you. That's quick and easy.
But the important one is down here with
analysis, it starts producing a series of
charts and some of these we've made on our own.
Let's say for instance, this one right here.
The idea is it makes a chart, It even
gives you a little bit of interpretation.
For every year donations increases by about
$10,300. That's fabulous. Now, you can also click
on this button, if you want to see it larger, it
fills it up right there and escape and go back.
Or you can even add it to make it a part of your
spreadsheet, I'll just click this plus button.
And now it's there in our spreadsheet.
I'm going to drag it over a little bit.
And then I can come back. I'll get out of that
one. I'll come back to explore and see what
some of the other charts are. We got a line
graph, it talks about donations increasing,
we've got this little stacked bar graph. December
2017 has the highest value for donations and a
value greater than most for events. And if we come
back up to the top, you see we can even click on
More. It'll do more of this. And so we come
back down here and then we've got scatter plots,
and bar charts. And donations went down
in 2016 October. Okay, that pie chart.
It's it's really kind of amazing. And this is
the sort of thing that as Google can team used to
work on their products, which they spend a lot of
time on, there will be more and more functionality
here. And so it truthfully, when you start working
with your data, you may want to go, instead of
waiting for the end, go at the beginning to
see what explorer offers you both in terms of
pre made charts, and even some suggestions on the
interpretation, it might save you some time and
give you additional insights that you might not
have approached through your own means. And so
it's a fabulous, fabulous addition to Google
Sheets to help make your analysis and your
applications easier. When you've made all of
your charts in Google Sheets, you've got a lot of
different ways that you can get that information
out there, you can share the individual sheets
with people, you can save the charts as images
and put them into presentations or documents,
you can copy them and put them onto websites. But
I do want to show you one interesting alternative
that works well, because Google Sheets is in fact
a web application. And that is publishing your
charts to the web. Now I'm going to begin
with one that isn't even really a chart.
It's this page right here, we just want to publish
this little bit of text based charts. And so let's
do this. Let's just come right up here to file and
to publish to the web. Now what is going to ask
is whether I want to do the entire document,
or just this one page or a particular page.
And what these are actually listed in our graphs
on pages, I'm just going to pick this first page
is going to ask whether I want to do
it as a web page or save it as a CSV or
tab separated file or a PDF or something
else. I'm going to save it as a web page.
And I'm going to hit Publish. And double checks,
which is a good thing. And then it gives me this
very, very long web address. Now, I'm going to
go to a incognito browser. So it's not logged
in for me. And I enter that and go to it. And
check it out. There is my chart. It's my little
repeat chart. And so it's not well formatted.
But the point is, it's there. And it's a way
of getting the stuff out immediately. Let's
try a different one, I'm going to go back to
where I was. And of course, this one. And
let's come down here to the line chart.
And I'm going to come down to this bottom one,
because I've got several different lines on it.
So this might be the sort of thing that
you want to share with other people,
I'm going to hit these three buttons right here.
And that also gets me to the published chart, I
could do it from the File menu as well. I'm gonna
hit Publish chart, revenue by source by month,
and I have an option of making it interactive or
making it a static image, I'm going to do this one
as an image. And by the way, you can see down here
is telling me that the repeat chart is published
Also, I'm gonna hit publish, it's gonna check with
me again, that's good. And I'm going to copy this
address. And I'll go back to this page, open
up a new tab, paste it in. And now you can see,
it's a web page. It's up here on docstoc
google.com. And it's a little fuzzy, because
it actually is low resolution that's about 500
by 300 pixels. I don't know why it's that small.
But it's available to people and people can
copy this URL and have access to the document.
Now I want to go a third choice. And that is let's
come over to the timeline, because I've got this
same data about revenue sources, revenue streams.
And I'm going to take this more complex one. Now,
one of the cool things about timelines is that
they are by nature interactive, you can come here,
say I want just the last one year, I want the
last six months, of course, it's going to bring
up this editing window. So I'll slide things over.
And you've got this little slider right here you
can use as a way of changing the timeframe
you're dealing with. That's all very cool.
So let's come up to these three little dots and
say, publish the chart. Now the last one I did as
an image, this one I'm going to make interactive.
So I'm going to hit publish, it's going to ask me
if I want to do that. I'm going to copy that
address. So it's already highlighted. Go to my
other page, open a new tab and put the address in
there. And what you'll find is it actually doesn't
look exactly the way it was before. It's arranged
a little differently. So for instance, these
three sources are listed on the left as opposed to
across the top. But you do get the numbers as you
go through. And you do have this zoom thing.
This is still available, but we've lost
the thing to drag across the bottom, the timeline
selector which is unfortunate because that's one
of the best ways of interacting. So not perfect,
not complete, but it is a really nice way to share
things by just giving people a webpage, give them
a link. And they can start interacting with your
data in certain ways and start getting some of the
same insights out of it that you had. Now, I want
to finish with one little thing here, I'm going to
close these three tabs. And that is, once you have
stuff published, you know, the time may come, you
don't want it to be out there anymore. And so what
you need to do is come down here, this is showing
us what's published, we can't scroll up very much
here. But you see the checkmarks, next to the
things that are published, just stop publishing.
And those links will no longer be active, and
the stuff is back in your private control. So
publishing is one interesting, not perfect, but an
interesting method of getting your information out
there, sharing your message, sharing your data,
and then being able to get insight from the people
around you. When people think about computers and
data, a lot of times they think about things like
machine learning and these artificial intelligence
algorithms that do these incredibly complicated
things. But it turns out that the vast
majority of tasks that we need to do with data
are simple arithmetic, addition and subtraction,
multiplication and division. And these are really
easy to do in Google Sheets with formulas.
But one thing we need to get started with is
cell references. So when you're writing a formula,
you need to have Google Sheets refer to the right
sell. And you can do this with what are
either called relative references or
absolute references. And I'll demonstrate both.
We'll begin with relative references. What I have
here is a list of the numbers one through 10.
And I want to take each of those numbers and I
want to multiply it times two. And I'm going
to start by writing a formula, all I do is I
type equals, that tells Google Sheets, I'm going
to write a formula. And then I click on the cell,
I want to multiply it's one over to the left, and
I multiply it times two, I do asterisk to great,
and when I do that, you can see a preview of
what these answers gonna be. I just hit it. And
there's a two, if you want to see again, what's
going on here, just double click on this cell.
And it will highlight the cell is referred
to and you see the color here is orange and
the matches here. If you have more than one cell
reference, it will do them in different colors.
But you can see that there's a formula there.
And then I'm going to click on that one. And
I'm going to drag it down. And what is going to do
is is going to maintain the relative reference is
going to say, at each step, take this cell that is
one over to the left, and multiply it times two,
if you want to see what all the formulas look
like you can do Ctrl tilde where the tilde on
the keyboard is above the tab. And that shows you
all the formulas and you see it goes to a three to
a four to a five, so on down to a 12 and
multiply times 12. That's a relative reference,
because all it says is go one to the left.
It doesn't say go to column A and although
it has an a written here, but it just is
interpreted as the next one to the left.
Now there's other ways to do it, you don't have
to refer just to the left, when we turn off the
view formulas, you may want to do a running total,
in which case we do a combination of things.
First, I'm going to write a formula
that says copy this one right here.
That's the simplest possible formula.
And then for each subsequent formula,
I'm going to say take the number that's right
above and to that add the number that's to
the left. Okay, so one above and add one to
the left. And if I take that and drag it down,
you'll see that in each point, it's taking the
number that's immediately above and the number
that's immediately to the left and adding them
up, and I get a running total of by the time
I get to the bottom here 110. That actually is
a useful thing to do. If you're keeping track,
say for instance of invoices, and you need to know
the total expenditures doing this running total
is actually how you would do it and relative
references will be useful for that one. On the
other hand, sometimes you say don't just go one
to the left or one above. But you need to tell it
to refer to a specific column or a specific row
even when you're moving things around. That's
where you get the idea of an absolute reference.
Now, I'm going to multiply numbers in this little
table. And I'll show you really how not to do it.
We'll start by saying I'm going to type in equals
to say so formula will take one to the left. And
I'll type an asterisk to multiply and I'll do it
one to the top. Okay, one times two is easy.
But watch what happens if I drag that down.
It's not going to do five times two here is
doing five times six. And if I drag that all
to the right, then I end up with some really
big numbers instead of this should be 30 down
here instead of 3 million. And so that's not
what we Want to do, I'm going to back that up.
Instead, I need to tell it that when it goes
to the left, it needs to always go to column E.
And when it goes to the top, it needs to always
go to row two. But even though it always goes
to column E, it will sometimes need to go to
this number or this number or this number,
depending on the row it's in. So we're going to do
a combination of relative and absolute references.
And the way to tell it to always go to one
particular column or one particular row
is to use $1 sign on the US keyboard that's
above the four. And that says, always go to E,
although it can adjust the row. And over
here, it says you can adjust the column but
always go to row number two. And when I do
that, watch what happens, I can drag that.
And now it works the way I want to. So if I click
on this one, you can see it's multiplying that
number and that number. If I click on this
one is doing that number in that number.
And if I do this cell is going to six times five,
which is 30. And so that's one way to do it. Now,
by the way, there is a more sophisticated way
of using something called an array formula here.
But that's a special circumstance. And I'm
not going to get into that. And there's one
other situation where you may want to use absolute
references on both dimensions. Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to recreate this table here,
by simply saying equals, and I'll come up here.
And I'm going to copy all those values.
These are relative references, by the way.
And there we go. So I've got them all there. But
I want to multiply each of these numbers times 10,
which means it always has to go to exactly
this cell, which is e eight. And so what
I need to do is I click on this formula here,
and I write an asterisk to do multiplication,
I'm going to click on this cell E eight, but
then I'm going to put $1 sign before the E
and $1 sign before the eight. And then when
I drag it down, it will always refer to that
specific cell when doing the multiplication.
So for instance, if I click right here,
you can see he's taking that
number multiplying it times that
here, it's doing the relative reference up to
here, but the absolute reference to this cell.
And the same thing here, relative reference
to this one, but always referring to this one
back. So that's the combination of absolute and
relative references. The way that you combine them
gives you more flexibility in how you create
your formulas, and more power and how you set
up your analyses. Some of the most useful
things you can do in a spreadsheet are also
the most basic. So I want to show you some of the
most important formulas, you'll use most often,
to get the first types of insight out of your
data. The three that I want to show you with
one variation on them our count and sum and
mean, a count is used to simply decide how many
values you have in front of you, it's getting
your sample size. And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this series of dates here.
And I've imagined, like we have a yoga studio,
and we've got the number of people attending a
group class on each day. Now, please note, one
of these is not a number, it's text I wrote down
because the Fourth of July is a holiday in the US.
But let's do this first one, which is count.
Now, I can do this two different ways I can
type equals and then the word count. But
because this is one of the basic formulas,
there's a shortcut to it. If I come right up here,
this is a Greek sigma, that's the summation sign.
If I simply say count, it inserts equals count
and then the parentheses and it simply wants to
know what data should account. And I'm going
to drag, click and drag over these numbers.
And when I hit return, I get 13. So there are 13
numbers here. The thing to remember about count
is it only counts how many numbers there are, so
it ignored this piece of text. On the other hand,
there may be situations where you need to
include even written things you need to include
any kind of information that's in the cell. And
in that case, you're gonna want to use a small
variation called count a, you can think of count
as count all not just numbers, but everything.
And this one, I am going to type out I'm going to
put equals, and then I'm going to type in count a
and that pops up right there. So I can
click on that. And then I'm going to
click and drag over the data. And then I'm going
to put a closing parenthesis and hit return.
And that tells us that there are 14 values
within this range of data. There are 13
numbers within that range. But there are 14
values, 14 cells that have something in them.
So counting can be very important just for
counting how many entries you have. Even
more useful, it's going to be adding things
up some. And some, it's really easy to do.
I'm going to put my cursor right here, select that
cell, and I'm going to come back up and hit some.
And it simply wants to know what data to add
up. So I'm going to click and drag over these.
And I have a sum of 170. So over 14 days, we had
13 classes at the yoga studio, and we had a total
of 170 people show up, which raises the next
question, if we had 170, people show up over
13 classes, what's the average number of people
per class? Now there's two ways to do this. One
is to simply take this sum and divide it by
the count. That is the definition of a mean.
But I can also use the built in formula for me,
which is nice, because it's going to ignore,
for instance, that piece of text in there as
well. So I'm simply going to have this cell,
come over here and click average, the average
and the mean, in most situations refer to the
same thing. It's where you get a total of
the number of people or the amount of money
the amount of time and you divide it by the
number of cases you're distributed across,
I'm going to hit average, and then simply drag
over these numbers, hit return. And that tells
me that have an average of 13.1 people in each
class period. Obviously, sometimes it's higher,
sometimes it's lower, we go from seven to 21, but
an average of 13. And so these are very simple
operations, simply counting how many numbers you
have, adding them up and getting the average.
But you're also going to find those are going to
give you an enormous amount of insight, the simple
operations are most often the most effective in
getting meaning out of your data. And these simple
arithmetic procedures are very simple to do
with the built in functions in Google Sheets.
More than anything, a spreadsheet, like Google
Sheets is a container for data. And one of
the important things to remember is that data
comes in lots of different forms. A lot of its
numerically based, but even then you can format
it in many different ways. And there is also
non numeric data. And Google Sheets can handle a
huge amount of this. And I want to show you some
of those variations. So you know what you can
put in and adapt to your own purposes. The most
obvious one, of course, is just plain old numbers,
like this integer 1587, you put those in there,
Google Sheets will usually put them flush, right
text is usually flush left, you can tap those,
and you can get a lot out of just those kinds of
counting numbers. On the other hand, you can also
get proportions which are red like percentages.
So this is 0.87 is the same as 87%. In fact,
if you want to see it as a percentage, you can
just take that proportion, and you can click
here on the format is percent key. And there
it is, it even gives you two decimal places.
But it's obviously 87%. You also have the option
of just typing it in as 87%. I'll do it like this.
And that also works as a percent. If I press the
percent sign there, now you see how it works.
Now, there's one thing you don't want to do, and
that is type in a number 87. And then think if you
do this, it can turn it into 87%, it turns into
80 700%, which is obviously not what you want.
So you need to start with a proportion, the point
eight, seven, and it turns it into percentages.
You can also put in the number like pi and you
can decrease the decimals, which is good because
pi has infinite decimals. So it can make a little
smaller if you want. Or if you have a number
with a lot of decimals already entered. And I'm
using the PI function here. You can increase the
decimals, I don't know that you really need a lot
more but they're available if you want them. Now
often the information you're going to be entering
into a spreadsheet is going to be financial, you
can have money, you're going to be keeping track
of purchases and payments. And you have several
different options. One is the accounting format.
So if you're an accountant, you're familiar with
this, but you come up to format to number and then
come down here to accounting. And what it does is
it puts the comma and for the 1000s. It puts the
dollar sign way over here. Okay, that's pretty
easy. You can also do financial formatting, which
is similar in certain ways. I'll come down here
and you'll see it puts in the comma but otherwise
it doesn't have dollar sign in formats a little
bit differently. And there's also currency. And
you can set your local currency in Google Sheets.
I'm going to use dollar, that's where I am. And so
you can see now it puts a little bit differently.
And it's three different ways of representing the
same information. Now, I realized they're slightly
different each other, it becomes a little more
pronounced when you make the numbers negative.
So I'm going to put a negative there, and now
you see it puts it in parentheses, that's a
common thing in accounting. And with financial,
it also puts it in parentheses. But when it comes
to currency, they appoint a negative, it sticks
in front of the dollar sign. So a few different
ways of dealing with money, depending on what's
the most common practice in the work that you do.
You can also put in dates, you just type
them in seven slash 16, it'll format them,
and then I'll show you in another video, there's
a lot you can do with dates in Google Sheets.
And you can also use time, so for instance, 10
1031, just enter it as hours, and then colon,
minutes, colon, and seconds. So those are all
numbers. And there's a lot of things you can
do with numbers. But Google Sheets is able to
handle a lot more than that it's able to handle
well. For instance, it can handle text, so
you can just type in words. And it turns out,
there's a lot of functions that allow you to deal
with words. And I'll give you examples of those
in a later movie. You can put in web links, if you
type in a valid web address, I just typed in data
lab.cc, my address, it recognizes that as HTTP,
although it should be HTTPS, because I have an SSL
certificate. And those are live links, you
can click on them, and it'll take you there.
So here for instance, I have my website data lab
now opening because I had it here in the cell,
the same thing works, you can put email addresses
in there, it'll work a lot of different ways.
You can put web data, this is an interesting
one. This is a special function that calls in
Google Finance data. So this is today's
stock price for Google $1,066 a share.
And by the way, notice that we get this
little disclaimer down here at the bottom,
if I were to delete that the disclaimer would
go away. Of course, you can use formulas,
and I've used a few of them already and have a
lot more say about formulas. So for instance,
the formula that pulls up this data is
Google Finance, and then in parentheses in
quotation marks goog, because that's the symbol
for Google on financial markets. And one other
interesting thing you can do in Google Sheets he
can't do in every spreadsheet, is you can include
images. Now, this is an image that is on the
web, it's it's my company logo, and you do
image and then you put the URL for that image in
quotes. Nice thing is if I make this cell bigger,
that you know it increases in size as well. So
you can put an image in a cell, if you can link it
from a URL, put that one back to where it was.
And then finally, you have the option of including
floating images and a number of other things. Let
me give you an example of that. I'm going to come
right here to insert, you can put in a chart, an
image, a drawing of form, checkboxes, columns, and
I'll talk about a lot of those. Let me just insert
an image for right now, the one thing you need
to know when you include an image, I'm just gonna
get one off on my desktop, I got my data lab icon.
The one thing you need to know is that it's a
floating image. And so it's not in the cell,
you can drag it around, it's also really big,
I'm going to make it smaller. So it's not linked
to this cell. And that's a little different from
this web image that we have in the cell. But it is
possible to include this information, especially
if you're trying to build up a repository
or even have a sort of a branding with your
spreadsheets, it gives you many different options.
And so what you can see from all of this is that
Google Sheets is able to serve as a container
for a lot of different kinds of data, each of
which might arise in different circumstances
in your own work. Numbers are probably what come
to mind for most people when they think about
spreadsheets. And that's reasonable, because
I'm willing to bet that most spreadsheets are
in fact filled with numbers. But spreadsheets
are more powerful than that and more flexible.
They can use text as well, which is good, because
when you're working in an organizational setting,
chances are you're going to have to work with
a lot of texts, like people's names and their
addresses and what their last orders were. And the
nice thing is you can work with that. I want to
show you A few specific functions that can be very
helpful in particular dealing with names in Google
Sheets. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you these using the name Ruth St. Denis. Now,
if you don't know Ruth St. Denis, she's one of the
founders of American modern dance. And even though
her name looks like it should be pronounced, Ruth,
Sandra, nee, she's American. So it's St. Denis,
the first thing we want to do is simply find
out how many characters there are in a cell.
And that's a really simple one, because
we have a function called Len for length.
And it counts the number of letters and spaces and
punctuation. So we have 14 pieces of information
in this particular cell. Great, that's a starting
point for a lot of other things. Now, we might be
looking for a particular piece of text. And
in this case, I'm going to look for the first
space, because for a lot of people that's going
to separate their first name from their last name.
And the function I use for that is called
find, you simply need to tell it, what is
you're trying to find. And I have quotation marks
with a space that they put in between them says,
find the first space in this cell. And return
is location, which is a number. And it's five,
because we have Ruth is 1234 letters and the space
is the fifth thing in that particular cell. Next,
we want to select the text up to the first
blank that is get her first name. And the
way we're going to do that is with the function
Left, left says start at the left in this cell,
and go how far I'm saying five characters. And
the reason I know five is because that's what
we got when we were looking for the first blank
here. Can we do that we get her first name, Ruth.
Now to get her last name, I'm going to
say get everything else. Now because
14, which is the total length minus five, which
is where the first space is 14 minus five is nine,
I'm going to simply do that. This one, however,
is going to be starting from the right.
And so I use the function right says
go to the end of this cell and then
count back to the left nine spaces that gets us to
the s and St. Denis. And there's your first name.
Also, a lot of times when you get information
in your spreadsheet, it might be a little weird,
you might have spaces where they shouldn't be have
spaces before the name after the name. And you
often want to clean those things up. So things
work a little better. So for instance, I have
Ruth St. Denis here, and you may not be able to
tell, but there are three spaces before her name.
And there are also three spaces after her name.
So we're going to get rid of those by using the
function developed specifically for this called
trim. And it gets rid of all of the leading
and trailing spaces. And so now we have Ruth St.
Denis without the stuff before after. Now, you
may have guessed that it's possible to combine all
of these in a logical algebra for processing text.
So for instance, maybe you have people entering
their names all in one cell when they're filling
out a form on your web page. So here I have Ruth
St. Denis, I want to split it into her first name
and last name, because that's how I want to store
it in my database, I can combine these functions.
And this is going to be a little complicated. But
here's how it works. I get Ruth, but the way I got
it, was it by first saying God has cell been nine,
that's where the name is, go to the left, and then
find the first space in that cell. And then trim
everything that comes after it. And when I do
that, I get Ruth. If I want just her last name, I
can use the compliment of that. And in this case,
it looks like this, we're going to do a
combination of get the right which is how I got
the last name, but we have to do the length of the
wholesale minus the space up to the first space.
And then we trim the extra stuff at the end. So
yeah, there's a lot of parentheses here. And it's
a little complicated, which is why I actually do
use this formula. I have a database with names
in it. And I do this to rearrange the way they
come in natively, so that they make more sense
to me. And so I have to use all this stuff. But I
tell you, it takes me a few minutes to get it all
worked out. But then I just copy it and drag
it down and it takes care of everything in the
spreadsheet. It's really nice. On the other hand,
what if things come last name, comma first name,
well, then you simply do a little bit of
rearranging. In this case, you're going to do
the trimming, you're simply switching what we had
here to over here. That's quick and easy. You're
searching for the comma in this case And you're
getting the stuff that it comes after the comma,
but trimming the spaces. And then the last
one is for the last name, you do have to make
one small modification here. And that is you
have to tell it, we're going to find the comma,
we're going to get the left part. But you need to
include this minus one to adjust the selection,
because you're doing from the comma, and then
you trim the blank spaces, and then you have
what you need. So all of these are different
functions. In fact, let me turn on the
Variable View the function view. And now you
can see what's going on as a way of cleaning
up organizing, getting the information you need.
So you can stick it in your own customer database,
and get it set up. So you can then process it
using other functions that can combine text,
and numbers and whatever else you need to suit
your purposes. One of the neat tricks you can do
in a spreadsheet like Google Sheets
is you can use formulas not only to
look at numbers, or even to select text, but to
start combining text with calculations, which
is sort of like doing a form fill on a letter. But
it gives you a lot more control and flexibility, I
want to show you a few different ways of combining
information. They all accomplish the same thing.
But they give you different approaches to it.
And depending on how many items you're using,
you might want to choose one or the other, I use
all of these in my own work. Let's go back to this
fictional example of say, for instance, a
yoga studio. And you've got seven days here,
and you're keeping track of attendance in the
group yoga classes. So you got 31 on Monday,
26. On Tuesday, things drop off by 30,
you're down to seven, then people feel bad,
and they start showing up there on the weekend.
And so you have 134 people total showing up in
those seven days. But let's find out how you
can use some special functions and Google Sheets
to combine that into a report. So I'm
going to come over here for a moment.
And I'm going to paste in a little bit
of information. First, let's put in the
beginning of a sentence you had a total of
and then we're going to put a formula here.
Now this formula is simply
referring to this data. Over here,
it's just the sum is the same formulas down
here. Okay, so we've got that. But now let's
put the second part of a sentence, I'm going to
turn off the formula display here for a moment.
You had a total of 134 visitors this
week. And so what this is, is some text,
a number that's derived from a
formula, and then a little more text,
we want to put them all together into a single
sentence. Now we've got a few ways to do this.
The first one is with this. Now, here's You see,
there's a problem with this one, by the way,
what I've done is I've simply said use this
cell, and this cell and this cell. So you use the
and sign the ampersand to get from one to the
other. That's great, except as you can tell,
it doesn't put spaces in and so you need to add
the spaces manually. And the way you do that,
is by inserting two more parts here. You
put in quotes with a space. And so it says,
Take this first cell, add a space, add the second
cell, add a space, add the third cell. And so that
works. And that can be a useful way of combining
the information and making sure it's formatted
the way you want to it looks like a proper
sentence. And it's not clear to people that
you're actually doing some math to make
these things happen. Another way to do it,
is to actually include the formula in there
itself, because in this one, I'm using the sum
that comes from appear. This one I'm including
a formula that refers back to the original
column. So there may be times when you want to do
the calculations in your sentence, or you simply
want to refer to the calculations that are done
elsewhere. Obviously, the result is identical.
Another option is to use the sentences
right there in the cell itself. So let me
highlight this one. This time I'm typing you had
a total of and I'm including the space in there.
Then I put the ampersand then I put the formula
sum, and then ampersand the and sign and then
quote and include the space here and then visitors
this week. And so the only thing that's going on
here is I'm inserting that sum that makes it
possible to get the rest of the information.
And then there are two other ways that we can do
this. There's a special function called Join. And
when you use join, what it does is it lets you
specify the cells you want to put together. And
the thing you want to stick in between each cell.
In this case, I'm putting quotes with a space,
and then comma and say join this one in
this one. In this one, I can also use
D two colon f2 to specify the range. But it's
a really quick and easy way. Sometimes when you
have a lot of things to put together, the join
statement is going to be easier. Although I find
the and statement where you're using the Add sign
can be a little clearer about what's going on.
And then finally, one other option is to
use join, but to this time, have the formula
for the sum right in here. So it's a self
contained statement. So it's referring
to this one joining with that joining with
that. Anyhow, you can use ampersand the and sign
as long as you remember to put a space in by
putting, quote, space quote, or you can use join,
either one allows you to combine text, along with
calculations based on the information. I use this
a lot in spreadsheets as a way of creating
a sort of mail merge, I use it to create the
subject lines for emails to have boilerplate
text for emails. And so I just have to copy one,
paste it into the subject, copy a second, paste
it into the text. And I'm good to go and is based
on a whole series of calculations combining
text that's in my spreadsheet. So it gives
you extra flexibility and extra power to work
with different kinds of data to get it to best
fit with your particular need. formulas in Google
Sheets can be used not only to multiply numbers,
or to select text, or to combine things like that,
they can also be used to do some basic formatting.
And what's really nice about this is you can use
these conditional formats, which are formula based
formats to highlight data bring your attention
to, for instance, to things that are performing
very well, very poorly, issues that need to be
resolved. I use them frequently to help me find
open cases. And let me just show you quickly how
this works. Start by selecting the text that you
want to format. So for instance, I'm going to come
here to teacher. Now, this is something that could
do easily on my own. But if you had a very long
list, you wouldn't want to do this manually. Let's
highlight a particular teacher. And so what I do
is I select this text, and then I come over to
format and down to conditional formatting, that's
going to open up a little window here on the side.
And it's going to apply to this range, see 339.
That's the range I have selected here. And we're
going to tell it, well, right now it says cell
is not empty, well, they all have stuff in them,
I'm going to say instead that the text
contains, and then I'm going to put the name
of one of the teachers Emmanuelle. We have
Kofi Alex and Emmanuel, and then I'm just
gonna leave this default, I can change the
color if I want by clicking on one of these,
I don't need to I'm gonna hit Done. And now, if
a manuals name pops up as the teacher, then it
automatically gets highlighted. And if I were to
change one of the other cells to say manual, it
would automatically inherit that, in fact, let's
do that right here. Let's change this one to say,
I got to spell it correctly. emanuelle ac,
it inherits the conditional formatting.
Next is what if I want to highlight not just that
person's name, but the entire row that they're in,
this is actually what I use, I use a
spreadsheet as a large database for
assigning teachers to classes. And when a class
isn't assigned as a staff, but I want the whole
row to highlight. And so I'm going to select this
entire rectangle of data. So not just the teacher,
but also the attendance and the dates. I'm
going to get the whole bit of information,
then I'm going to come over to conditional
formatting, I'm going to add a new rule. And the
rule I'm going to add is a slightly funny one,
you may not guess this one, I actually have to
come down here to custom formula. And what I want
to tell it to do is if the teacher is a manual,
then highlight the entire row. And it goes counter
intuitively like this. I write equals and then the
dollar sign seeds, they always look at column
C and then 13 is there because that's the first
row in the block. And then if that cell is
equal to a manual, and because it's text,
I have to put it in quotes, then highlight it
So that's what we've got right here. I hit Done.
And you see how it's highlighted. And again,
if we were to change another name to Emmanuel,
you see how the entire row inherits
that highlighting. And again,
this is really useful for identifying important
clients. It's for identifying unassigned cases,
it's useful for identifying any number of
situations that you can describe with a formula.
And then finally, another good one is what's
called a color scale. I'm going to come over
here where I have the information again, I'm
going to select just the attendance information.
And I'm going to select a new rule here. Now,
not a single color, which is what I've been
doing so far, but a color scale. And what this
does is it lets me choose a range of colors
that go from the minimum value through the
midpoint up to the maximum. Now I don't want
the green to be the low and I'm going to switch it
the other way around, I've got some choices here.
I'm going to pick this one. So it goes from
white to green. And it highlights the higher
values I'm going to hit Done. And what you
can see now is that the darkest screen is on
the day that we had 31 people, the white
is for the lowest value, which in this
set is 12. And so it can give you an impression of
the range of the data. And again, maybe things you
need to focus on, maybe you need to figure out
what's going on the low days, maybe you need to
figure out what you can do to increase the high
days. But Conditional Formatting in any of these
situations with the color scale, with highlighting
a single cell with highlighting an entire row
is a way of using formulas, again, not just
to manipulate numbers or to manipulate text,
but to manipulate the highlighting and drawing
attention through additional visual cues. And
it makes it a lot easier to work with your data
and find the things that you need to make sense.
Congratulations, you've made it to the final
video in Google Sheets. And you may be wondering
what to do next? Well, I'm here to discuss
a couple of possible next steps for you.
In learning to work with data and
learning to work with Google Sheets.
The most important thing is to do it yourself
gets started and get mixed in with things.
You want to get some data and you just want
to try see how things work in Google Sheets,
do a little bit experimenting, a little fiddling
around, see how it behaves and what you can get
out of it to serve your own purposes. Now, what
you're going to need to do is get some data.
Now chances are you already have some data where
you work you may have if you're in an organization
that does email marketing, you'll have the names
and the email addresses and location information,
maybe information about open rates and
click throughs on your email newsletters,
that's a great place to get data, you can
download that from your email service provider.
You may have social media data, things like who's
following you who's commenting where they are,
when they last interacted, what they said and
how they connected and how they share things
and what they really believed about all of it.
This is information that is also available
to you through the analytics of your
social media host like if you're using buffer or
Hootsuite you can get this information and start
putting it into Google Sheets and see what
you can do. Also, you may have sales data or
some other kind of interaction, you might know
what kind of items people are buying, or what
services are requesting, whether a first time or
a repeat customer, and also the path to purchase,
did they click on a thing and Instagram and get
to Facebook and get to your web page. And that is
a lot of information that can be very helpful
for businesses and for service organizations
to start better understanding how people are
interacting with them and how they can reach out.
If you have that data available to you download
it, see what you can do with it in Google Sheets,
beyond what you can do with the built in analytics
of each of these programs. Also, you can get free
data. For instance, data.gov is one of the best
sources of open data in the United States. You
can search for a lot of other different sources.
Here I'm showing I went to data.gov. And I typed
in the Word Art and looking for data sets on art.
I have over 11,000 data sets found and you know,
you just click on this little CSV, which stands
for comma separated values. That'll download
a spreadsheet that you can open up in Google
Sheets, and you can get started with open data.
You can also get data from Google Trends. And
that's a service from Google that lets you see
over time, the relative popularity of different
search terms. Here I've got two German operas
deflator mouse and Rosenkavalier. And you can see
that for instance, the second one was more popular
back in May of 2017. But the first one has been
more popular since then, you can download that
data by clicking on this button right here, and
start seeing what you can do with it in your own
analysis. Finally, there's Google correlate one
of my favorites services that lets you look at
the popular search terms over time, like we had
with Google Trends. But it also lets you look at
state by state comparisons, where it gives you
a number in terms of the actually its standard
deviations of each state in terms of the relative
popularity of a search term within that state.
One of my favorite ones here is the search for
modern dance. And you can get that information,
you can download it right here by clicking
on CSP. And just in case you're wondering,
this state that is head and shoulders above
every other in the entire United States,
in terms of searches for modern dance, is right
here in Utah where I live, it's one of the more
shocking things in terms of data driven insights.
Now, there's other things that you can learn. And
I suggest that if you start here with Google
Sheets, you might want to try to learn some
more things. So for instance, here at data lab cc
available either right now or in the near future,
our courses on data principles, I've been showing
you the tools, and I've been showing you how to
work the tools, but the concepts, what does it
mean to do a regression, what does it mean to
have a standard deviation, I'm going to talk
about those things. And these other courses.
I also have sets of courses on the other
applications within the Google Drive Office
Suite. So that's things like Google docs for
preparing reports, and Google Slides for making
presentations, Google Forms for gathering new
data through online surveys. And of course,
there's the Microsoft Office complement of
all of those Excel, and PowerPoint and word.
In addition to those, if you decide that
you need more than a spreadsheet can do
easily for you, you might want to try
statistical software. I suggest jumbo V,
a new and not very well known but immensely
wonderful application that you can download,
upload your CSV, and start doing high quality
statistical analyses. It's free, it's open
source is it based on our, but it operates with
drop down menus that make analysis very easy.
Also, SPSS is a common choice in a lot of
different fields in nursing and education in the
social sciences. We have courses on SPSS, and if
that's the one that's most common in your field,
try to get your data into that and see what kind
of statistical modeling you can do there as well.
And then, of course, if you want to go beyond
that, you could try statistical programming
in languages like R and Python, we have our first
course and are currently available, Python will
soon follow. And in any of these, you're going
to be able to build on what you've done in
Google Sheets, the the insight that you've gone,
and you'll be able to build on it to get more
statistical modeling, more predictive analytics,
more ways of finding what you need. And so
it's time to get moving, get some data, get
going. I'm so grateful that you joined us
here at data lab.cc. I hope this has been an eye
opening experience and an opportunity for you to
get working with your data to find ways that you
can run your organization, your business and your
own personal projects more effectively and more
efficiently. Thanks for joining me and good luck.